the only person you should try to beat
is the person you were yesterday
yes
is that something yeah i believe that
wholeheartedly i think that there's this
i don't know i mean i don't know where
it comes from but there's a sense of
competition in in the arts and
everybody is looking at their peers the
person next to them and they're trying
to make sure they're
one-upping that person and trying to be
better than that person
and
then they start following these weird
trends and you find everybody doing the
same thing and their only sense of
growth is that their sense of gross
growth is measured by
how far they've distanced themselves
from the next person
and for me that's just
that's not the case it's it's a it makes
it very tough to grow and i'm always
trying to learn and grow in everything i
do and the only way you can really
measure that growth is if you look at
the work that you've done before
and how much
more you've improved
how much closer are you to achieving
whatever it is you see in your head
because when i sit down and i write i've
seen the movie in my head and when i
step on the set i'm ready to bring
whatever's in my head
to the screen
and how
the way i gauge my own success and the
way i gauge my own growth is by how much
closer
have i gotten to that
with each project i feel like in the
beginning i was at maybe i think one of
the first films i did i said i was
probably got like five percent of what
was in my head on the screen because
it's all about learning how to
communicate
and work effectively with everyone on
the set you know
it's about the team where the teamwork
makes a dream work right and it's about
learning how to work with your team how
do you deliver the information that they
need in a way that they can understand
and execute
effectively
and
with each project i think
you're supposed to grow and get better
at that communication
and
you know you can view the work to see
your growth but if you're constantly
measuring yourself by what everybody
else is doing where is your real growth
true let me just play the devil's
advocate for a second though because
sometimes you can have a strong mindset
like that but then you get
individuals from the side and they want
to rope you into their competition
and it's up to you to say oh i don't
think i'm playing today
um but but we're human and we get you
know i mean look the movie eighth grade
for those of us who remember being a
female in eighth grade it reminds me a
lot of that you know and there's still
an aspect of that to adult life and
especially in entertainment and so how
do you handle when you can tell you're
being challenged and roped into some
kind of weird competitive thing and
you're saying no this is my path my lane
is here your lane is there
and i think fortunately i
i haven't been wrote in that i do know a
filmmaker who
i i think they're in competition with me
but i think that that's all in their
head because in order for it to be a
competition two people have to be
playing um but i don't bother to
participate because i know what it is
that i'm trying to accomplish i know
what my lane is and and the the kind of
projects that i'm looking to create and
how i'm looking to create them and
realistically
the only person in that lane is is me
and even if there was another person who
was doing this the same or something
similar i would give them whatever
knowledge i have to help them succeed at
whatever they're trying to accomplish
because that's the way we all win is if
we're all helping each other
i think that if you look at
let's just say the the top one percent
in hollywood right
they all really know each other
in some form of fashion this guy knew
that guy who worked with this guy and
they came up and then this guy reached
back and helped this guy and then this
lady helped this guy and this guy helped
this lady that's how it all went
everybody helped everybody get to where
they are
by not considering themselves
competition by only wanting to see
their peers succeed
i think that's the way it works so even
if i did realize that someone was trying
to to rope me into this this competition
i would just say
what do you need from me to help you
that that's the conversation i i'd
rather have how can i help you
how can i help you i want to help you
grow and help you succeed i want to help
you be the best you possible
so
let's start working on that let's have
that conversation
you would he would really do that if you
even if you saw like their sort of
underhanded tactics you would really
want to help
well i because i guess their underhanded
tactics what would they be for me i
don't know what they would be for me
because i don't report to anyone i
finance my own projects so who how can
they be underhanded what i mean i guess
if they were trying to maybe
you know influence an actor to not take
the role or something like that and i
would just tell them ah that's not cool
that you did that but uh
i guess it serves some sort of purpose
for you you get some kind of
satisfaction out of it but whatever
because ultimately it's not going to
change the fact that i'm still going to
create this project
it's it's not going to really change
that fact
and did you notice that more when you
came here to southern california or or
it was the same in georgia
people are people everywhere yeah i
think people are people everywhere i
think that
here it's it's it's
there's a bit more
you know fuel pushed into the fire
because the stakes are so high
and the opportunities are so small
i think that
you know that puts a little bit more
fuel in the fire
but
in saying that the people who
i found that i worked with repeatedly
are people who they only want to see
everyone around them succeed they're
constantly trying to find
opportunities to to bring in more people
that would find some sort of benefit
from whatever they're doing
and
that's what's made me keep working with
them and i see them being successful as
well i see them being successful now
and it's it's all because they'd much
rather focus on
reaching back and being of use
than
trying to compete
just be of use like i told you that was
one of the things i learned from john
singleton be abuse be helpful
never ruin a good day
by thinking about a bad yesterday yeah
that's a good one yeah
leave leave that stuff in the past
whatever it is leave it in the past it's
not it's not helpful
it's not helpful um i found a lot of
people who sit back and still talk about
that film they made that one time that
many years ago and this person
ticked them off and it was this person's
fault and it was that and it was this
and it was
leave that stuff alone leave it in the
past learn your lessons and take those
lessons moving forward and apply them to
whatever you're trying to create today
if you keep focusing on what happened
yesterday
you have no appreciation for what's
happening to you right now in the
present and you definitely can't really
plan for the future because you're too
busy thinking about what happened
yesterday yesterday is gone
it's gone
so just just leave the problems of
yesterday back there and take the
lessons you learned with you
like that one story of the guy that
drives around with no rear view mirror
and they say how come you don't have a
rear view mirror and he says i don't
need to see where i've been
that's a great one that's a great one
i'm not sure if it's a real story but
i've heard other people say it so yeah
um
do you think we can really live without
pain and regret do i think it's possible
to live without pain and regret
i definitely think so
i definitely think so i think that um
[Music]
the
pain is just your way of uh well in in
some instances i can't speak to all
kinds of pain because some pain comes
from the grief of of losing someone or
you know so so i can't speak to that
type of pain but i can take to talk to
the pain of any regret of making poor
decisions and i think that ultimately
that kind that type of pain that type of
regret
is you understanding you've done
something um
you've done something
wrong
whether it be just incorrect or
something actually wrong
and you need to actually fix that and
learn your lesson from that move forward
and take that lesson with you if you are
constantly growing from the things that
are happening to you in life if you're
constantly taking those lessons and
moving forward to make sure they don't
happen again i do think you can live
without that pain and that regret that
type of pain and that type of regret
yeah certainly
justin can you explain to us why having
a plan b
i believe used to be very important to
you and then it changed
oh yeah that's easy if you have a plan b
you'll most often use a plan b you'll
never go as hard after plan a if you
think you have something to fall back on
throughout my entire life everything
i've done has been
somewhat involved in the arts i i you
know i told you before i drew comics i i
wrote stories short stories uh i was in
the band i did you know i was in in the
in the chorus as well i'm not a good
singer though i was
but the thing about it is it's always
been in the arts and
the arts have always been something i
pursued but i've always been told always
have a plan b always have a plan b
always have a plan b so even going to
college i had a plan b i knew that i
wanted to be in the arts i knew that i
wanted to write
but
i all i fell back on on uh on rotc
because i'd always been in rocc even in
high school so i fell back on that and i
had something to work with if nothing
else worked i could you know take up
something in the military but
ultimately
as i moved further and further
throughout this career and i grew more
and more inside of the career
in this industry i started to realize i
never went as hard after
my plan a because i was always focusing
on keeping my plan b healthy
and all that energy that i was putting
into plan b
and constantly thinking of
if if this doesn't work i can escape
here and if this doesn't work i can
escape here because i spent so much time
doing that i was taking away a lot of
energy from plan a where if i had
invested all of that and went full bore
into that
you i would have been
much more successful quicker i think
that i do believe you know opportunity
means preparation and maybe it was the
opportunities were coming along much
later but i think i would have created
all new opportunities had i focused
really hard
or and just more on plan a i think that
warren buffett said you know you only
have to be right 51 of the time that's
it you only have to be right 51 of the
time to be successful and if you were
throwing everything you had at plan a
the chances of your success improve
greatly
you know did you steal
i don't know too much about rotc but
how much of that training or being
around like minds helped you sort of be
resilient
and maybe take things less personal than
others might take um
well i think that more than anything it
teaches you accountability and
responsibility and when you hold
yourself accountable for something it
doesn't really matter other people's
critique of whatever you do is it's
either constructive or not and if it's
not you just toss it away because you
yourself are holding yourself
accountable to a higher standard than
than most other people would hold you to
anyway
um so i that's more than anything else
is what i took away from rotc just that
accountability and and the
responsibility
sure so showing up
not only showing up but but showing up
and being prepared more prepared than
everybody else is know know as much as
you possibly can about everything that's
going on and try to make try to apply
that to whatever your specific task is
you know
what kind of heart does it take to
pursue this business or is heart not
part of the picture
um
heart
meaning
passion
it has to be
something that um
it has its own rechargeable battery
i don't think i think you have to go
hard i think you have to go hard all the
time and you have to
uh
i know for me i i i was having this
conversation while i was saying before i
hear a lot of people say oh i die to
make a movie i die to make a movie and i
say i would never die to make a movie
it's not there's tons of stories you can
tell and all that stuff but i got to
finish one because
with all the planning and everything
that goes into making a movie
it's having that passion that's going to
help you finish a movie
because for all the movies that are out
there that you can think of
think about it this way if you saw a
hundred movies
there were probably
50 000
that got they started making but never
finished
and of that 50 000
there were probably a hundred and fifty
thousand scripts that were in
development and about to start
production
so if you look at that number and it
filters all the way down to just 100
films it's not about
getting the opportunity to make a film
it's about finishing a film and that
takes a passion where you where you have
to go into it with the understanding
that no matter how excited someone is
about your project be it the actor the
the cinematographer
the editors anybody who's working on
that film that's not you
those people for as excited as they are
they do not care as much as you do they
never will
so when things start breaking down and
it's got to be spit bubble gum and duct
tape to keep it together and to keep it
moving it's going to be you
it's going to be you and the second you
get tired and you can't finish it that's
when it stops
that's when it stops
because you you're the you're the person
you're the battery you have to keep
recharging that battery that passion you
have to keep it going and it has it has
to push you all the way through
every adversity and every um
every obstacle
to get to completion
that has to push you
and it can't die ever because that's
when the project will just cease to
exist and once it's once it stops it's
very rare the projects get picked back
up and they finish them it's very rare
so i would i would say in terms of heart
i'd relate it to passion
and say that yeah it has to be a
rechargeable battery that just doesn't
die it can't die now if you're saying
what kind of heart in terms of
caring and compassion and that sort of
thing
i don't know how far that gets you
i don't know i think if you if you get
into films that are very much about um
uh
society and how to push society forward
and make people think about the world
they live in and that sort of thing if
that's the direction you're going in i
think that having a heart is
for compassion and and love and and all
that great stuff i i think that it's i
think that it's it's paramount in that
because
there it takes a great amount of will
that willingness to understand people
and open yourself up to to learn about
others and to learn about their cultures
and whatever it is that you're going to
be talking about in that film it does
take a great amount of of heart and
compassion to do that to be willing to
to completely immerse yourself in
someone else's world
but those are two very different hearts
i think two very different hearts
sure and there can be a downside to the
other heart and that things can affect
you too much i mean there's been
documentarians that have ended their
lives because they saw things they
didn't want to see yeah about different
countries or wherever and the atrocities
that we're going on so that can it can
also take you down
because there are things you cannot see
and uh and once you're made aware of
them your deep feeling for those things
it can affect you in some profound ways
in ways that you you don't expect
you know i i i
i will never forget um
there was a time back in what was it
maybe
maybe oh nine
was it on nine maybe all nine oh nine i
was doing marketing for a skilled
nursing facility
and
it required that i have a nursing
background but i said you know there's
nothing i can't learn so of course i had
to you know really hit the books and
learn a lot of nursing terms and things
of that nature
but i digress
the thing was is there was a patient of
the skill nursing facility that ended up
in the hospital and i had to go visit
them
and just kind of see how everything was
going make sure social workers were on
it and everything and they told me the
guy wasn't going to be
released because now he's definitely in
need of a stay because he has a stage
for decubitus ulcer and i was like stage
four to keep it holster i've heard of
those those are bad and they're like
yeah they're bad here's a picture of it
and that picture i cannot see
i can't unsee it's a it's when a bed
sore
has basically eaten its way to the bone
almost
wow and when i saw that i was like ah
why would you why would you not like
give me a second before you did that
that's permanently
in my mind and now i associate it with
this patient that i've grown to care for
so now i'm i'm more like
emotionally invested in this person and
makes it hard to do my job now because
you're the only thing you're thinking
about is there to keep this ulcer but
you forget the other reasons why they
were there in the first place the only
thing you want to do is make sure that
gets healed because that is the most
painful thing that someone can go
through
it's an incredibly painful thing and if
you if you've ever seen it of stage 40
to cupidus ulcer
i apologize to you in advance that you
had to see it because it's it's a very
nasty wound very nasty wound
you know did well maybe this is too
personal we can cut this out so i'll ask
it and if you don't want to did you move
on from the job i did i did i eventually
i eventually had to move on from from
working in a skilled nursing facility it
was
it was a place where you you get to know
everyone by name you know and
you get to
to learn their dietary needs and
everything you know so much about you
know more about them than their families
do
and you spend more time with them than
their families do
and you begin to care about them deeply
and
to to always
after it happens the first few times
when someone that you know and that you
speak to every day passes away it's like
it's a huge shock
and
it's something about that realization
when there is no longer a shock
and that was the moment i realized i've
been here too long
when i changed from
talking about people that i know and
that i care about when i stop it
saying that they've passed away that
they've died i stopped saying that and i
started started using the medical
terminology which was
they expired
that's when i knew
i
i think i need to step away from this
it had become death had become way too
clinical for me
wow yeah did you take time
for yourself after that or you had to go
into another job right away
i no i took a little time away i took a
little time away as a matter of fact i i
think that that was the impetus to make
me say i i i really just want to focus
on the arts i i really
i started having conversations with
people and
i i don't know how it sounds now i
really don't know because back then it
was so clinical
and
it still feels clinical when i say it
but i started telling people
i've seen the end
live your life the way you want to go
out
because ultimately that's what's that's
what we're all doing we just don't know
it but we're living our lives the way we
want to go out
so
either your mind's going to go first or
your body
but live your life the way you want to
go out
and
as i said that more
i realize you know what i
i will
i will start feeling that regret that
i'm not supposed to feel
if i don't
now start going 100 after my plan a
that's when you'll start having that
regret when you see an opportunity that
you let pass by
and
doing that actually led me into
uh the film ax men at cutters creek
it really did it was because i left that
and i just sat down and really just got
back to writing and said i just want to
pursue this and i want to shoot a film
by this date i want to forget everything
i've been doing before this and i want
to shoot this film
and so that's what i did i just devoted
all my energy to that and funny enough
a doctor
that i met actually ended up uh
financing that film
and so it just worked out you know in
that way but uh the impetus for that the
the thing that pushed me to get away
from that and into this
was that realization
and sorry this was the first accident
the first accident okay so 2012 2013
yeah we shot it in 2012 i believe yeah
2012 is when we actually shot it but
before that it was it was me writing and
going to everyone and trying to figure
out who was going to finance this thing
and
you know it eventually worked out it was
the first time i'd done that before that
prior to that everything i'd done was
self-financed
and then
i just realized this one's too big of a
film for me to finance on my own
and so i did go around looking for
um you know a financier or producing
partner somebody to help me get the
movie
made
and so you were we were coming out of a
recession
and so with money was tight for a lot of
these investors or yeah money was very
tight and two
there's a certain amount of
vanity and ego
that comes along with i guess sometimes
financiers so that made it
that made it a little tough it made it a
little tough uh it was very funny i
learned a very
an interesting lesson i have a buddy of
mine and and uh i don't mind mentioning
his name he won't mind either his name
is eddie l watkins
and he's a very big stunt coordinator in
the business and he's producing now as
well
and he was in these meetings with me as
we were going around and everything and
one of the one of the investors
said you know what i i would just prefer
if we do
these scenes the way i've written and he
hands me pages that he's now written
to rewrite my script right
and so he hands me these pages
and he hands one to eddie
and we're in this meeting and eddie
doesn't even read it he just looks at me
and i'm reading him looking at eddie
and i'm like i don't understand why you
would do this this is not you know i'm
trying to give him my notes on what he's
written and the guy is puffing up his
chest you know he's doing those things
and again eddie's just watching
and uh the guy won't accept any notes
he says to us look
this is how the film needs to be written
if you want my money because he who
makes the gold
he who has the gold makes the rules guy
actually said that wow and eddie without
missing a beat says that's only if we
want your gold
and i look at him
and he says yeah we're walking that's it
meeting over
and we literally walked out of the door
and that was it i thought we finally had
a guy you know and and he was you don't
want to work with a guy like that
because if you don't if you can't get
along with him now and if he has no
flexibility now he'll have none during
production and he'll think that every
idea
is supposed to end up on the screen and
that's not someone you want to work with
especially if their ideas
don't work for the project
and it was very funny because walking
away from that we eventually walked into
the investor that we did use yeah it was
a very scary time because i walked away
from that job and i spent a lot of time
trying to get the ball rolling but
what i did was i took plan b
and i tossed it
and everything that came
below that no plan c d no escape routes
no nothing i want to make this movie
and i want to make it next
and that's exactly what happened because
i didn't give myself an alternative i
didn't give myself
you know
a way out of it a way for it not to
occur
when you met with the he who has the
gold makes the rules person
how many investors in was that how many
meetings in was that a first meeting no
that was probably our second
okay that's probably our second or third
yeah probably our second or third
but you you and and your your friend the
stunt coordinator both just had like a
gut reaction like if it's bad now
this is the honeymoon phase it's not
going to be it's not going to improve
well
here's
here's the back story to that which is
that eddie has been in the industry
forever
he started out as
eddie murphy's bodyguard
that's how he started out and eventually
he got into the industry as a as a you
know a stunt guy and he eventually got
into the place where he now coordinates
all the stunts and
he has just a long history in the film
and he has a lot of experience so
he gave me many life lessons along the
way
but in this one
he
he'd done it so much where he didn't
even need to read the paper it didn't
matter because this is the guy who wrote
it and he knows if it's good or not
that was his only point i would know if
it's good or not and if it's not
appropriate for the film we're not going
to do it
so that's that's how that decision got
made
we republished this tweet from the
numbers game on our channel page and it
says squid game creator wrote the show
in 2009 but was rejected by studios for
10 years he once had to stop writing the
script and sell his 675 laptop due to
money troubles and today squid game is
number one i guess in 90 countries and
is set to become the most watched show
in netflix
history
what is your reaction to this the story
this chain of events
i mean
if it's true it's awesome um i i
it's it's that
feeling of of the never say die attitude
no matter how much rejection you get you
still keep plowing forward and i love
those stories i do um
i think that
i always
if the story is is
completely third party then i i feel
that it's it's an awesome story of
perseverance
but if it's a
netflix story which i i i'm a netflix
subscriber i i definitely watch it but
they can tell you what's number one and
you just have to
believe that it's true we have no way of
verifying that it's number one
only that they said it was number one
that i always wondered that whenever i'm
looking at the
the like this is number one for the week
and number 10 for the week i'm like how
do we really know that that's number one
in number 10
it's just because we went there and they
told us that it was so
um but like i said before if it's the
story if the story is true and it's you
know it's a third-party story that's a
great story of perseverance um i i think
that we
people are born with a lot of quit in
them for some reason or maybe it's
developed over the years but when they
start to reach those obstacles or any
kind of adversity it's it's very easy to
to give up
and
unfortunately i think that we all have
people in our lives who care about us
greatly they care about us deeply and
they will see us going through some
adversity and it's like oh man it's been
years you probably should maybe maybe
you should start thinking about
something else because they care about
you and they want you to be successful
and they don't want to see you kind of
beating your head against the wall and
they'll sometimes advise you to
maybe maybe throw in a towel on this one
and i'm pretty sure he had that person
next to him telling him that
and
when i always hear about people who have
those
advisors with them i always say find new
advisors
because
the only thing that
people should help you understand is why
you care so deeply about what you're
doing
that's always the real question why do
you care so deeply and after that they
should just be trying to help you
achieve whatever the goal is you're
trying to achieve
or give you the best advice they could
on how to achieve it you know
i know you said you left your
job as a marketing coordinator at a
nursing skilled nursing facility
but have you ever been tempted to give
up on films as many
rollercoaster rides as you've been on it
sounds like
no
no i i've had times where it was tough
and
ultimately you had to feed the safe you
know you have to say okay you know i
gotta
focus on putting money over here and
this and that but
i've
i
they always say that the the line
between
uh self-belief and delusion is very thin
and i must be riding that line because i
i've just i've always believed
especially after i left the skilled
nursing facility that is this or bust
is this robust and
i'm very very fortunate that i've gotten
to a point where now i self-finance all
of my projects
and
you know i
i think that i can i can service two
different demographics i can service the
horror crowd which is what most people
know my work uh from is horror and in
that like 80s style horror and then i
can also serve a niche of people who are
like me who like the kind of stuff that
i like and that's a smaller niche but i
can still serve that niche and that's
where i get to
um
really be the most creative that i could
possibly be
but
that took time to get to that point and
it took a lot of sacrifice to get to
that point
and
i think
there are moments in everybody's life
where they realize that
man this is very difficult and i wonder
if the juice is worth the squeeze at
this point
but it is my belief that
once you start to feel that
that's when you should be your most
decisive in going forward
and the reason is because
success
and everything you're looking for is
just on the other side of that
it's it's when you don't have the teeth
to keep going and you give up you you
cut yourself short and you always wonder
what if i had just kept going what if i
had just
given it another this or made that one
extra phone call but i never want those
questions and what i found is right when
you have when you get past that point
everything i was looking for was just on
the other side
it was just on the other side
and i'm starting to reap a lot of the
benefits of that perseverance and
continuously going forward
would you say that's one of your biggest
fears is the fear of regret you don't
ever want to get to a certain point and
go i wish i had just done this tried
harder
um
no i i think more than anything i just
i don't want to feel like and it's going
to sound really weird but i don't want
to feel like life beat me
i don't want life to beat me i've seen
life beat so many people most people
around me life beat them when you ask
them what happened what did most people
say life happened man i had it there and
this happened in that
i don't want life to beat me i take
everything that comes with life
and i try to use it to my benefit
everything you know at this point my
wife is is is pregnant right
guess who's going to be in my movie
my kid
he's going to be the star of the movie
you take everything that's coming to you
and you use it
whatever happens in my life i use it if
it's if it's something crazy and wild
happen it's a story in the script
if this happened it's in the script i'm
taking everything that comes it comes
towards me and i'm using it i'm using it
as fuel i'm using it as something to
keep moving forward
life won't beat me it won't
we're hoping to get your reaction to
this comment and that is this is not a
triumph it's a tragedy and it's a sign
of just how much the industry needs to
do better because creative original work
should not be just a long struggle to
put it out
referring to the squid game
and
what are your thoughts on that
um
he didn't let life beat him
no he didn't let life beat him but to
say it's not a triumph it's a tragedy
it's like wow really
i don't i
look
you
everything that we do especially in this
industry everything you're trying to do
is met with resistance and opposition it
just is
it is if
the way i try to explain it to certain
people when they say oh it's nepotism
and this person and that and this is why
i can't get in and
okay
let's say you are trying to to get
through the door
okay
in every film i've worked with let's say
we take the collective of everybody i've
worked with in that film maybe seven
percent of them are people i actually
work with again
maybe
okay
and it all has to do with the way i run
my set
and what i expect from people
in the end not everybody is gonna
operate at that same level okay
and while i can be very chill i can also
be pretty intense you know
now because i'm very passionate about
what i'm doing
so
if that's the case
after a certain amount of time i'm
hopeful
that the percentage of people that i'm
working with
is growing
so that now
i'm carrying over most people from one
project to the next why am i doing that
because these are the people that i know
these are the people that i trust
okay and i want to keep them next to me
and i want to keep them working with me
so when the next person comes along and
they say well guess what i can do this
and i can do that
i say you probably could
and you're probably great at it
but then i would have to take a chance
and
maybe on this project i'm already taking
these chances i can't afford to take
that chance
and that person can see that as
an obstacle to their growth into their
success because they couldn't get
that position on that film they couldn't
get that thing out there and if they go
to more and more people like me who
begin to accumulate a nice team that
they work with a very a team that makes
everything work smoothly
they're going to meet that same
opposition
right
and it will become
a game in terms of trying to find that
crack
to squeeze in to get whatever it is that
you're trying to to get made made
so
when people speak of the struggle to get
things done that's really the struggle
the struggle is
first of all he's written something
right
and
he has to get it in front of someone to
read it well guess what
there's hundreds and thousands of other
scripts
that are trying to be read
everybody's trying to get their stuff
made
the key is going to be the perseverance
and to keep going and that to me is the
triumph of the story as i said if it's
if it's the true story and it's
you know a third party and they're
talking about it
to me that is a triumph that's not a
tragedy it's a triumph
you took something that is not a very
um
it's not a cheap story to make like he
can't go out and get a a
camera phone and shoot that like it
doesn't work the same he's gonna need a
serious budget guess what that's even
more competitive because to get people
to spend the
millions of dollars it's going to take
to make that and market that
that's tough
it's very competitive
and it shouldn't be easy because if it
were easy wouldn't be worth it
so
excuse me sorry um i i disagree with
that it's it's not a it's not a tragedy
it's a triumph
what was behind door number one what we
didn't tell you what was missing from
that tweet
um is that director huang did not stop
during those 10 years he kept working
and he wrote and directed i guess three
projects
during that time and a lot of people
um they may have just been stuck on that
first one
and trying to make that one happen so
he
for whatever reason kept going and made
other work and
i i don't know the exact story of how it
happened but um
it sounds like he wasn't
going to let life beat him down either
so yeah it's a story of perseverance
like i said he he may feel that it was a
tragedy he may because you know
two people looking at the same event can
see two totally different things right
to me that's not a that's not a tragedy
to me that's a triumph and hearing that
he made other projects while he was
trying to get that one made even further
you know uh solidifies that
it's it's perseverance at its best
and it's never giving up and
his plan a i don't think was just to
make squid game his plan a was to to be
successful and get something made and
that's exactly what he was getting done
squid game just took a little bit longer
than the others but
ultimately he got that one done as well
when you were
on your way out from the nursing home
did people try to talk you out of
leaving
yes
yeah
but
i always make sure that i seek first to
understand and then to be understood
and
i could understand why they didn't want
me to go because you know i was a
salesman and i was pretty you know
decent at what i did so
they didn't want me to leave
because then that meant that they would
have to find another salesperson and
then they'd have to take a gamble you
know and see if that person would work
out and when it comes to
the healthcare industry especially when
it's end of life and it's it's uh you
know assisted living facilities at
skilled nursing facilities home health
and hospice
is super competitive
it's super competitive so you need very
aggressive salespeople and that was
ultimately why they didn't want me to go
i mean i think there were a couple
people who just like talking to me every
day yeah
and those people didn't want me to go
and i think a few of the patients but i
think or residents i should say but um
for the most part it was it was because
of my skills that they didn't want me to
leave and
once i understood that i said that's
even more of a reason to to to kind of
leave and not feel too bad about it
you know
well they try to talk jeff bezos out of
making amazon so well there you go
can you talk about the decision that you
were not going to make movies by
committee anymore and what does that
mean
it's
for me it's it's it's about it's going
back to accountability and
being able to hold myself accountable
for for not growing for not achieving
the level of growth that i need to
achieve
when you're making a movie by committee
which i understand completely that most
industry movies are made by when it's
you know a studio or whatever
but
going through that many
levels of decision making and you know
this person believes they know what's
better for the film they know what's
better for the audience they know what's
better for marketing they know
i believe you need one voice
we need one voice
that ultimately makes the decision of
what to do inside of the film you can
definitely confer with everyone around
you when i hire an actor
i hire them because they are the best at
what they do and they fit this role and
when they read the script they're going
to be able to tell me
things to a level of detail that maybe i
haven't thought about right
and i trust their intuition and i'm
going to figure out a way where we can
kind of make that work inside the film
but that's not what i mean by committee
what i mean by committee is a
executive producer who now says you know
what and this is a real thing that
happened
yeah i think we need a topless scene
right now
and how
there's in what way you know it's like
at what time would somebody take their
clothes off that doesn't even make any
sense uh there's a murderer running
around and everybody's in the same room
like what would be the reason that they
would need to you know it's like a lot
of those decisions that are just made
because people want to be heard and they
want to see whatever they've said show
up on the film it's a vanity
and ultimately when you're making movies
like that and by committee with multiple
people having all of this input your
film is getting further and further and
further away from what you're trying to
achieve and as i said the only person
i'm really competing with is the person
that i was yesterday i'm constantly
trying to grow and how can i measure my
growth if
everything around me is being affected
by people who are not me
and people who've already articulated
that
it has to be in there or
you know basically they can withdraw
funding that's ultimately what it is is
that the decisions when they're being
made by committee are made by people who
can ultimately make the decision of if
you won't do what i'm asking you to do
if you won't put this in the film i can
withdraw funding and i can do it at any
time i can do it at any point because
again
they're not as invested in the film as
you are they're invested in their own
vanity a lot of times not not all the
times there are some great financers out
there and some great executive producers
but
unfortunately i haven't worked with them
you know but the ones that i've worked
with have been
kind of vain and and it has been the
vanity of having whatever was in their
head added to the film even if it
doesn't make sense
story-wise
sure and and
in any relationship where someone's
giving you money they they kind of own
you in a sense they do they do
and especially when you know that they
can pull the plug and it's the reason
why i have overlooked a lot of the
things that have been done on on the set
you have to let a lot of things go
and try to control the things you can
control
um
but
along the way
this committee will continuously try to
influence everything that you do and it
makes your personal growth
and measure you can't measure it because
it's not really you it's you plus that
guy and that lady and that kid you know
it's it's you plus all of this when it
should be you
making the sole decision now you can
take
inspiration from what other people say
you can take
some advice from what other people say
if it applies if it's applicable
but you can ultimately decide if it's
not
and i only began to get that sense of
freedom when i started to
to finance my own projects
that's when i began to see it
what kind of sacrifices did you have to
make to be able to finance your own work
um
security
financial security oh yeah for a while
for a while um financial security um
a lot of things that
probably so many to to too many to name
but things that would have certainly
made
my young lady happy
we had to sacrifice a lot with the
sacrifice a lot of time that you would
normally spend together i was holed up
by myself doing so many things myself
because whatever you can't pay for you
have to assume that responsibility
yourself
so even when we would be sacrificing
financially
um
we were also sacrificing just the time
we got to spend together
and it was it was very hard time in the
beginning a very hard time
um but here's the thing is
and i don't advise that people just run
out and start self-financing their own
stuff i i would say before you do that
understand how distribution works
because once you understand how you make
your money back
then you can justify how much money you
spend on a project
right you don't want to
give yourself you don't want to take you
know a loan out for eighty thousand
dollars hundred thousand dollars and
make a movie that you're only going to
make five thousand dollars from you need
to stack as many of the of the statues
stack as much of the deck in your favor
as possible
so but you know in the beginning i
certainly had to sacrifice financial
security and i had to sacrifice a lot of
time
and
spend a lot of time away
from my lady you know
and i've been away from my family since
2004. i go back home every once in a
while to georgia but for the most part
my family has seen me on average maybe
once every three years
to maybe maybe every two years but i
probably lean towards the three i don't
go home
that often
so
there's been a lot of sacrifice to get
to where i am today
and when you're writing a script
is it now in your mind
that okay this is going to cost too much
and i'm not going to make my money back
on this i have to change the scene
no i i i'm always aware of the story
that i'm writing and
the budget that it falls within
i make sure i tell the truth in the
story
and
budget should never dictate truth
but budget should dictate what you're
trying to do as a whole i don't think
you should make a sci-fi opera if you
only have two thousand dollars i i think
that that's a
that's setting yourself up for for
failure i think that if you're going to
tell
a
very intimate story between two
characters that
you know
they met outside of a motel you know in
the parking lot and they're developing
this romance over two days at the motel
and one guy is there on a business trip
and the lady lives there yeah whatever
but if you're trying to make something
very small
and
mostly just the conversations that they
have between one another and those
that's easy to do and that's very
inexpensive
but if one of them is a cybernetic
organism
and they shapeshift and uh they walk
they walk through these wormholes that
constantly open up and now all the
machines are coming out to attack
everybody and the motel blows up then i
think you've kind of set yourself up for
uh
for um
for failure
you used to rely on investors to make
your films
now you don't and we'd love to know the
economics of what you did when you had
investors and now what you do as a
self-financier
um
i would say that now i make
less
financial mistakes
um when i worked with investors
i i knew enough to know that
i was always going to need a reserve
right so whenever i spoke to someone
about the budget i always said make sure
we also have you know this much in
reserve
and i wrote the script and most often
times more often than not i would have
to use that reserve
and
you would often find that you're using
that reserve in post-production because
more of the money got used in production
than you thought would have been
as i've now began to do it myself i
budget i budget actually over what i
would actually need and i try to save as
i go along
you know as opposed to the you know
working backwards where you budget just
enough and then i was like oh this cost
more than i thought it would or you know
maybe we missed a day and then we have
to add another day to production or you
know you you don't realize the problems
you're going to have until you start
having them
and that was what i was going through
during the period of time of having
investors
so now i i think i make less financial
stakes less less uh budgetary mistakes
and scheduling mistakes now that i'm
financing it myself and it's mainly just
because i have the experience
you know
and how are you able to save because you
know how
different things can happen
there can be rain and you have to shut
it down for the afternoon different
things
what are some of the things you've
learned can help actually save
on production
uh
we always have
you know you have the schedule as it's
supposed to be but then we know that if
we have days where
weather impacts shooting then we have
like a safe shoot so we always know okay
these are the things we're going to
shoot but if on any one of these days
you know rain is not permitting or
something happens out on the road or
whatnot we can go back and we can shoot
this inside and that way you don't lose
any days you're just moving things
around in the schedule i think that
one of the
i think about this day and it's just
i'm like how could i be so crazy we were
shooting axe man actually and
one of the days the the executive
producer showed up
and uh
for whatever reason he came in we were
shooting one scene inside and then we're
supposed to be shooting something else
outside and then it just started pouring
rain
and so we came in and we all sat down
and we just waited for the rain to stop
hours we waited for the rain to stop
instead of shooting anything else we
were actually shooting something indoors
already and then we stopped shooting
that because that was over and then we
decided to shoot outside when we
couldn't shoot outside we didn't shoot
anything and it was a completely lost
day like i want to say four hours of not
shooting when we could have been
shooting any number of scenes and shot
inside
and that was one of the biggest
takeaways from that is once i thought
about it i was like i am
i am nuts for allowing that to happen we
should have moved on and shot something
else
so
i you know as again i learned a lot of
things early on that i carried over into
you know
the ones that i executive produce now as
well
and so that's
all the lessons i've told you every time
something happens you have to learn that
lesson and carry that lesson forward and
that was that was one of the ones that
you know i certainly learned so i always
have backups for you know exterior
shoots
so even if you have to shoot something
out of order
then as long as just just keep keep
everybody there and keep it rolling yeah
yeah the only the only film where that
would have been tough was the one i just
finished shooting once and one
that one
we had the
we had the complexity of the beard
because his beard was either there or
not there
and so everything with the beard had to
be shot you know together so you
couldn't jump the line and go shoot
something else because
you know he's not supposed to have a
beard so
you know that was the only one that
presented an issue
how much money was going into your
movies when you were dealing with the
financiers
um you know we we always made sure we
didn't spend more than a hundred you
know we never spent more than a hundred
i really
unless you're shooting with
massive names or if you're shooting
something that of course
if it's something that is going to use
up most of the budget like we i just
finished working with someone who was
doing a film where you know it's
dinosaurs and
it's a very different thing right so so
a lot of money is going to go towards
you know cgi and all that stuff so
um
but if if you're shooting the kind of
movies that i shoot that rely on
practical effects and you know things of
that nature
and the stars are not huge and stuff
like that i don't believe it should go
over a hundred
i believe anytime you're going over a
hundred
you're really rolling the dice i think
you're rolling a dice anyway but you're
really rolling the dice over a hundred
because
i believe that with a
smart marketing plan even with a bunch
of flaws
you can make back a hundred
if you go to 250 you go to 350 and you
don't have huge names attached
or if you don't have a whole lot of
marketable elements
you could you could dig a hole that you
can't climb out of
so it's always been under 100 and i try
to keep most of my movies under 100. and
if you factor in a lot of the
the discounts i receive on things
you could really see my budgets kind of
coming in at around 250. you know that
that's what they would be like if i was
being charged full rate for a lot of
things
and so 100 sorry for the entire
production including post and
deliverables and and
prints and advertising yes okay
and were all those films profitable that
had financiers attached
i would say that
in the beginning
no
they didn't they became
they became
more profitable after i got them back
and after i marketed them myself
the reason being is this and that's why
i just gave a one answer
a one word answer of no and
the reason is because
earlier on i thought
if i give my film to
a distributor
then that distributor is going to market
my phone they're going to sell it all
over the place and then i'm just going
to break in a bunch of money
and
it'll be awesome
and that's not really what happens a
distributor
basically places your film
and
if no traffic gets driven to those
places you don't make any money
so ultimately it's your
job your responsibility as a filmmaker
to drive traffic to that film
or to to drive traffic to those places
where it can be purchased right or
rented or whatnot
so if you're not doing that you're not
making money and if you this i mean back
in the day when sales agents really
mattered um
that sales agent could take the film and
sell it here and sell it there and sell
it there but
nowadays that doesn't really matter
unless it's a huge film or it has a very
huge name attached even though those
things don't matter
so you have to understand
not only that it's your responsibility
to do so
but you have to also understand how
to accomplish it how to drive traffic to
those places so that you make money so
no when those films were released
they were not profitable then but they
are profitable now
so it's not just enough to get a
distributor to put it on itunes or
google play or whatever you've got to
have a plan in place to get eyeballs to
go to those links correct correct that
was that was one of the biggest lessons
i had to learn and not only learning
that that was my job
but figuring out how to do it
because it can be very tricky it can be
very tricky because
the
the amount of films that are out that
are constantly coming out is just crazy
and if you think about it as as
filmmakers most filmmakers think
oh this person's in the film this and
all these people know other people and
everybody's talking about my film
amongst each other oh man i'm doing it
it's huge and it's like no because
you're just talking to other people in
the industry
and yeah everybody else in the industry
is talking about it but
they're really not your audience and
they're really not the people who are
going to make your film a success
they're not unfortunately the audience
is the people who you're marketing the
film to in terms of a paying audience
who that's their interest
that's that those are the people who you
want to be aware of your film
those are the people who you want
talking about your film
and
as i began to notice it more and more i
even took my own personal
facebook page down i took it down
because it was
for what i was doing it was worthless
and it was a waste of time because
everybody who i knew worked in the
industry and we all pumped each other up
and oh you're awesome and that stuff
doesn't matter that stuff does not pay
the bills you know pumping each other's
ego up is that's all it's doing is
pumping you pumping each other's ego up
so i got away from that completely and
just started really focusing on how do i
find my audience
and how do i keep them engaged
and then how do i best convert that
audience to a paying audience
how do i best do that
and those were things i just learned
along the way
so maybe your audience let's say
would be the people that would attend a
horror convention in middle america
rather than people on either coast that
are also looking to be cast correct okay
yeah but unfortunately and you don't
know it
really on on
on like when you're on like a
me social media platform like facebook
and everybody's friending you friending
you like oh my movie's so popular
and it's only
after you
sit back and you look at it that you
realize man every single one of these
people are either actors or composers
like
what is this like i got seven thousand
friends well i've
five thousand friends and
four thousand and eight hundred of them
are other actors and and composers
you know like that's that's the the list
of uh and that's not my audience that's
not who i'm really looking to
to convert you know those are the people
who i'm looking to keep engaged they're
already engaged because they're looking
for work
you know
so
you know i had to learn how do i
how do i find my audience and how do i
keep them engaged how do i keep them
happy and
i really started to notice when i got ax
man back and i just kind of put out a
blurb about it guess what guys i got it
back
and then everybody was like oh that's
awesome blah blah blah
and what are you going to do now oh i'm
going to re-edit it oh you're going to
re-edit it how is it going to be
different and people were actually
really engaged and we had a lot of back
and forth and i had people writing me
you know i always thought this should
have happened in the movie i'm like
we already shot it it's like it's
i'm re-editing but i'm not going back
and reshooting things you know it's been
a while i think everybody's age at this
point but um you know just looking to go
back and re-edit it and then get it
closer to the vision that i had for it
and they were just so excited and
engaged and when the movie came out it
was instantly great i mean it was
instant instantly profitable and one of
the coolest things about it was i didn't
even release it for people to
rent or purchase i released it directly
to
amazon prime and 2btv
and that was it
just those two just those two platforms
now it's since expanded
but just i would even say
even if you remove amazon from the
equation which you know
if most filmmakers haven't
they should
in terms of av or in terms of svod you
should remove that from the from your
overall vision of how much money the
movie is going to make
and really focus on places like 2b
because that's where i would say
95 of the revenues come from has been
from 2b
and with 2b are there forced ads
yeah okay so you you have to watch the
ads sure you have to watch tv
and i think every movie it starts with
like two or three ads and then it goes
into the movie and then a few minutes in
it's another four or five ads and then
they go and so
if you keep people engaged if you have
quality content you keep people engaged
each time they pass one of those
commercials you're making more money and
so you know that's the name of the game
is is avod for for certain movies for
certain movies now if you have
a movie like you know like the my most
recent film one-to-one if you have
something like that where you have you
know a couple of names that are in the
movie that people recognize that's
something you want to really push and
see
what tvod has to offer transactional
video because
the odds are a lot of people will go
there to rent or purchase that film
because they recognize those people and
because the content may be something
they're interested in
did you use an aggregator to get it on
to be or
amazon prime or these other you said uh
with the v
sorry with the watson want you yeah yeah
yeah uh with
the smaller films i go through filmhub
actually filmhub is a great resource
because mainly because i think
for most people the barrier to entry is
too high
from going with a traditional aggregator
because they're going to charge you per
platform they're going to first of all
have a set fee and then any platform
after that is another fee and another
fee another fee and another fee right
now if you anticipate
and when i say anticipate i don't mean
hope but you've actually done the
homework
and you anticipate making
i don't know
uh
500 grand right unless i'm just going to
use that ballpark figure if you
anticipate making 500 grand from your
film and you went through an aggregator
then you paid them up front
so that's all they got so if you paid
them if you paid them up front and it
was
2500 bucks
then that's all they got and you got all
the rest of that money
but if you went through film hub
well film hub you didn't pay anything up
front they take
i think it's i think it's ten percent so
if they're taking ten percent then they
took fifty thousand dollars
which is huge
but
if you anticipate because you've done
the research and you know films in your
certain budget range they maybe only hit
a certain number
then and you know that you're gambling
anyway
then filmhub is better because there's
no real barrier to entry
you can just put the film in see how it
does
and
let's say you you crap out at ten
thousand right game's over it's made up
it's made ten thousand and from now it's
petering out um
then you didn't spend anything to get
into the game and if you if filmhub
takes their percentage they've only
taken a thousand dollars
is there a period of time when the film
kind of peaks or depends on the title
in terms of like viewership is it the
first month
i think it all depends i think it
depends on your
how you've promoted the film or if you
even know anything about promoting
because
i didn't in the beginning and i know my
film came out and i know people were
watching it
but i had no idea how they were watching
it
i never sent them anywhere to watch it
um
it grew a following but i i don't know
how much of that was
how much of that was from them finding
the actual places where it was being
shown and watching it through there or
just watching a pirated link i would
have no way of knowing
because i never i never invested the
time in understanding how to market to
an audience
so i didn't have that
information at my disposal
but um you know as i
as i
moved more into understanding the
marketing of a film
i can say that
i usually will feed that audience engage
that audience and then
point them to where i need them to go
and i can watch the film through every
quarter actually with filmhub because
you know you can piece out the rights
you can you know take the rights and do
this by yourself and then filmhub only
handles this but of everything i'm
seeing i can see it month by month
what's happening
you know and see how much money i'm
generating how many views i'm getting
month over month and i usually find that
in the first quarter
that's where you get
the larger number of people viewing your
film because that's when it's still hot
that's when it's most exciting and
everybody wants to watch it and see what
happens
and then it starts to kind of
find
a little medium
and it rise that probably for another
two quarters
and when you say peace out the rights
what does that mean meaning you own it
in perpetuity but then they
own it for a certain time certain amount
of uses no actually film hub doesn't
they you're not even
you're licensing it to them but it's for
no predetermined amount of time
so at any moment you can just stop it
you can say you know what i'm not liking
this anymore i'm just going to stop it
now
and you can choose to do so
and
what i mean by piecing out is
you know if you're going to i mean it's
different now but in the beginning if
you wanted to keep amazon rights for
yourself because ultimately why would
you want somebody to upload to amazon
when you could do that yourself
so for a lot of people they kept the
amazon rights themselves
and then they would put the rest of
their
you know the rest of the platforms on on
filmhub
and then they would make all their money
that way
and so
as
amazon has moved away from allowing
direct uploads for a prime
they've moved away from that recently so
i say recently like it was just now but
i think it was beginning of 2021
they moved away from that model so yes
you can upload your film and it can be
tvod for rent for purchase but it won't
go to amazon prime
unless it was put up by another
distributor or an aggregator
really do you know why they did that
i mean the rumor is that
it was because so much of prime was
cluttered with
not that quality content because people
were saying oh it's a feature film and
really it was just a bunch of episodes
of uh
you know something they put on youtube
like you know like like uh you know them
um what was one of the ones that was
like a tutorial on
something like nails and stuff or
something they just put together a bunch
of episodes and it equaled out to like
45 minutes and they just uploaded that
and now that's considered a movie and so
i think amazon just they got enough
backlash from that
um and they decided you know it's it's
not worth it for us to allow people to
do that now we need somebody curating
that content i think that was part of it
i think the other part of it too is
ultimately amazon creates their own
content
and so
you're even though i know i know a lot
of people think that
we're not really in competition with
with amazon because
you know they have these huge big shows
that are watched by hundreds of
thousands of people if not millions of
people we're not competing with that and
essentially yes you are you just
not you
by yourself
but if you and you and him and her and
we all got together and there was a
thousand films that hit amazon prime
if you add up
all the people watching that content it
is rivaling
their shows
it's taking attention away from the
stuff that they've created
so i think it's those two reasons
in tandem
that really pushed him to make that
decision and say you know what i think
let's put an end to this let's make it a
curated thing where
at worst i'm sorry at best they're going
to have to go through
through film hub
you know and and i think so many people
still don't know about film hub
and i think if you if you knew about
film hub
as a as an independent filmmaker you
would never rely on another predatory
distributor again you never would
because you realize they're completely
inconsequential you can give your film
away to this guy over here who will make
money off your film and you'll never see
a dime or you can do it yourself and put
it on film hub and chances of you saying
money is far greater
you know
it would keep people out of making some
really bad
bad deals with
distributors with bad intent
you know and do they have certain specs
that they require aspect
yeah
yeah yeah yeah they they do
they do specify the the formats that you
must submit and they do specify you know
how many moments of black you know that
you can have so that the films are
pretty uniform so you're not having more
than i think
more than
two seconds of black at the beginning
and not more than two seconds of black
at the end that sort of thing just so
that movies start you know because i
know there are people who try to pad
things out and oh you know if i throw on
two minutes of black at the beginning
and
five minutes of black at the end you
know my movie's now
83 minutes
so i think they try to do that but but
ultimately it's just something to keep
it uniform
why have you put your films on 2b
at the moment it's probably the greatest
revenue generator
because people get to watch it for free
it's a free
app that's
in pretty much
i would say almost every
english-speaking territory and even some
non-english-speaking territories so it's
widely available uh just as much so as
amazon prime
and
you know it's it runs off ad revenue so
it's completely free unlike amazon prime
where you have to have a membership you
know whatever you pay per year your
annual membership with 2b you just
download the app to your phone or to the
computer or to your television
and
you know you're able to watch films
completely for free just everything all
the revenue is generated from from
advertisements so
we recently heard that a filmmaker
said that he made like six figures
from toby um can you tell us your
experience
uh six figures yeah definitely possible
uh i think it depends upon
a lot of factors i don't know if this
filmmaker did it on one film because
that's a different set of factors versus
he just had a bunch of his films on
there and that's a different set of
factors but depending upon the factories
yeah certainly
all it really all that really needs to
happen is that you drive an audience
that you've been interacting with
to to be
you know the only the only pushback i
would say i received in terms of of why
someone hasn't viewed a film of mine on
2b was just that they didn't know what
to be was they didn't know how much it
was going to cost so they didn't bother
to download it
that's the only thing i think that as
more people become acquainted with 2b i
think that's going to be the place to go
to to place a film and i've actually
been in in talks with them so that i
don't have to go through an aggregator
in order to place films there because
all they really want to see is that
they're not dealing with a filmmaker who
has one film they want to deal with
someone who has multiple films so that
they aren't just dealing with one offs
of having to have different bank
accounts to pay or whatever so that's
why they deal with aggregators that's
why they deal with distributors because
they're just paying
one person for a lot of films versus
one-offs
so you don't have let's say a dashboard
within
2b that you can go and see what you made
for this quarter
i don't have it because i don't have a
direct relationship with them yet but
i'm about to have a direct relationship
with them uh for right now i see all of
my revenue projections from filmhub
okay right
why do you place such an emphasis on
owning your own movies
i believe that that is the only way to
operate with any type of freedom in this
industry
to be tethered to
a committee to be tethered to someone
who holds the purse strings
it just
already this
this industry you have to have a thick
skin already
and it's an artistic industry it's not
like it's
you know being an accountant or
something it's it's actually
you
relying on your own creativity and your
ability to
take what's ever in your head and apply
it
in reality to make it come true right
you're trying to do all these things and
then ultimately you have so many people
around you that are
that could be whether it's negatively or
positively influenced in that and
manipulating it and they don't mean to
they don't mean to it's not like i don't
think many people are out to just screw
you over with bad ideas i think that
everybody just wants their own thing
they want their own imprint on whatever
it is
and
it really hampers your your freedom and
your ability to grow but if you if you
were able to finance your own projects
and you were able to
uh understand the distribution process
so that you understand how much money
you generate from that
then
you've taken so much of your own
financial freedom and your creative
freedom into your own hands
that's why i really emphasize owning
your own rights and
not i don't even license my stuff out
unless i know that this person can do
something that i can't do and even then
i'm only licensing the rights to them
for the things that i can't do on my own
that's it
because i know that if i licenses it
licensing to them for
i don't know
two three years that's two or three
years that i'm tied to them on this
specific thing and if i learn how to do
that in that specific in that during
that time i can't even do anything about
it because they're already doing it so i
have to wait until their license is up
before i can do it myself because
i like to i like holding me accountable
i like making myself responsible because
that's the only way i know for sure 100
that it will get done
and get done to
the level that i would do it or that i
want it to be done so
in all of this what i'm trying to do is
take all of my projects
and use them to not only express myself
artistically but also to provide my own
security moving forward
you know
how do filmmakers continue to make
movies if their films aren't profitable
they can't
not from any standpoint you can't do it
if you
rely on investors and you can't do it if
you're relying on yourself financially
the best thing that i can ever recommend
is but that's why i always say i always
give
before i tell someone oh make it
yourself i tell them to learn
distribution
and learn
what your
specific film
what on average does that film kind of
make
based on a number of different factors
and then you try to stack as many of the
marketable elements into your film as
possible so that while you're being
free creatively to create whatever you
want to and to finance that you've
stacked a certain number of things in
your favor to make it profitable if not
for you for the person that invested in
the film you know
how does someone really learn
distribution though
without
really having gone through sort of the
the
heart school of hard knocks with it
that's the that's the catch-22 i think
that everything that you learn about if
you if you watch a video
and someone explains to you this is how
everything works and
that's how it worked when they made that
video because it's already changed
things that worked in 2014
don't work today
they just don't because as equipment has
become cheaper
and
the ability to market the film has
become more democratized
more people have started making films
than ever before
now
anything that you've learned leading
into this period of time
you've been able to build upon
but if you're now watching things back
then about how the industry works you
are so far behind you're so far behind
the best way that you're going to learn
is to take a certain amount of money
that you can afford to lose
and get in the game
that's really the best way that you're
gonna learn it if you've got a thousand
dollars
you can make a film
and i'm telling you this because i made
a film that's in distribution and it
cost me 1500 bucks
and it's on to be right now i think it's
on to me
which is adam k right
that film cost me 1500 bucks and
i have a name in it you know
fair abraham who she was number one
trending on twitter at that time
uh but yeah roughly 1500 bucks is what
it cost me to make that film
you can do that and you can get into the
game
that's the best way that you're going to
learn how to do it
because
trying to
to gather that information from things
online i think you'll end up being
behind the ball when it comes to
distribution specifically when it comes
to how to write a story when it comes to
how to cast actors when it comes to how
to produce a film when it comes to
development when it comes to those
things those things
are integral to getting the film going
but the conversation that needs to
happen before that is the one that keeps
changing which is distribution
because all that affects everything else
until you get to that point
and that's the part that just keeps
changing you know
so the best way to understand it is just
shoot something
just shoot something anything
it's so cheap to do so right now
it whether they have the the iphone you
can plug the little anamorphic lens
adapter for 100 bucks on the back of it
and then you're shooting something
just go do it understand
unders understanding the windows of how
to release things is important
you know
but you only learn all of those things
after you've distributed something after
you've already
invested in it or you've gotten someone
else to invest in it
so it's like
if you're
in a flight simulator or you're let's
say playing some day trading game unless
that's like your real money or you're
really flying that plane
you're not really going to learn i mean
it's going to be you're going to take
more chances and different things and so
when you really have skin in the game
it's different yeah it's very very
different it's very different and i'm
going to tell you it's so funny that
when i was making a film by committee
with you know financiers and stuff
and
i would say i you know i really believe
that we should have this in the film and
and this and it would help
give out all these great ideas but it
was coming from a creative standpoint
right
and
at that time i hadn't really learned
about the marketable elements like why
this film needed to be made and why does
it need to be made this way
those were the things i didn't
understand or i should say i applied all
of those
questions to
the creative part of it and not
the distribution part of it
and i had all these ideas and it was
like ah but if if someone had those
ideas today and they were asking me
about making a movie i would tell them
to stop
just
stop what you're doing right now
i'm going to explain to you why
that's not the conversation you should
have right now right now you should be
defining who is this film for and don't
say yourself
don't say yourself unless you know a lot
of people like you
and you know how to reach them
don't say that
figure out who your audience is for this
movie
because if you know who your audience is
you'll know what's important to them and
you'll know if what you're talking about
is important at all
especially if you have to spend money
because every idea you come up with all
i hear is a cash register
that's all i hear because it's going to
cost money in order to do it so just
make sure that it benefits the film
somehow financially
and if you've got enough marketable
elements sure be free go off and do you
know whatever you know in mid-sentence
make a wormhole open and the guy gets
sucked in and you know whatever i don't
whatever it is you're thinking about
doing just make sure that you've done
the homework up front to define your
audience
because that's ultimately what's going
to matter
are you able to know
the exact moment like let's say
a film is paused and re-watched or where
people drop off
with your movies do you know it to that
much the analytics are that strong for
you
yes and no
uh you know it through amazon
you don't know it through the others and
that's only because you're going through
an aggregator that aggregator has that
information but they typically don't
share that information
but uh if it's if it's if it's amazon
prime you can definitely see where
people are falling off
and and and you know you'll sometimes
rack your brain wondering why why why at
this moment and you go back and you look
at you can't see it but there's there
are things where people just they fall
off for whatever reason but yeah you can
see it you can see it i i think in all
honestly that's how i don't i don't know
if this is bad to talk about or not but
with
netflix
people have started to become a little
bit disenchanted with the content
sometimes right
and they always say it just seems like
like there's no real connection
and i said well
there may be a reason for that
because they can see the analytics and
they can see when something drops off
maybe they think they know why
and they go back and they look and
they're like oh i see because yeah there
was before that this brunette was in it
and she walked through and then she left
the scene and then people stopped caring
so that's what we need we need more
brunettes we need more hers or whatever
that's what it was it they don't know
but they think they know because they
have they have the analytics and they're
looking at it and trying to dissect it
and figure out what any of it means and
they're doing it to such a granular
level that it's got to be maddening but
i think that's what they're doing i
think they're using that same
that same stuff to try to figure out how
to make movies that keep people engaged
more because ultimately that's why it
exists is for you to see and for you to
know
that people are falling off
do you think making a successful
independent film is like winning the
lottery
it depends on your definition of success
i mean if your definition of success is
you made a movie for
10 grand and it made 10 million
that's definitely a lottery ticket
i don't think that there's any way that
person planned to do that
but my definition of success is
how much closer did i get to the vision
that was in my head when i was making
the movie
how much closer did i get did i get
closer this time than i did last time
because that's a success for me and one
one day i want to be able to look at a
film and say i got exactly what was in
my head
because i you know
pleasing this guy or this lady whatever
like that that's not really what i'm
making films for
what i'm making films for is to
to get closer and closer to the movies
that are in my head i wanna i wanna
i want to
get all the stuff that's in here on a
page and from a page on the screen and
do it in such a way where i didn't
compromise
too much
you know i didn't compromise too much
if
you know if your successes
who you got to be in the movie or who
who saw your movie and you know reached
out to you i think
you know quentin tarantino was trying to
make reservoir dogs as a short film
and his success is that he made it to
i want to say he said he made it to
harvey keitel or somebody and that
person was like are you crazy this
should be a feature you know that's a
success
you know you were going to make
something small and then it became huge
that could be a success it all depends
on what your definition of success is
so
that vision it sounds like has always
been there because when you went to that
one investor
who said here are my notes
and it's my way or we don't make this
thing
you knew that no it had i really want
what was in my head to be on that screen
this isn't going to work for me well
i would say it wasn't as strong back
then the only thing i knew was that his
notes
or his new
scenes didn't fit the film
it just didn't fit the film like
to give you an example
there's a there's the people go walking
off to go look for this guy
and
he wrote in a scene where one of the
characters
lady pulls up in a in a jeep and her
like oh how'd you go back and get the
jeep and she's like well my father used
to race you know jeeps back in the day
through the desert and like what does
that have to do with anything it was
just it was the most
useless piece of piece of backstory and
why would they have a vehicle if they
had a vehicle then they could just leave
like it was just it opened the thing for
like why it doesn't make sense in this
film
and that was the reason why i didn't
want it in the film not because it
wasn't part of my vision
but because it just didn't fit in the
film and none of the things that he
wrote fit in the film
now i would say if if someone comes to
me and they can give me very sound
advice i had it on the previous film
where somebody came to me and they said
i just
i don't really get this and then we
talked about it and i realized
wow from a really objective sense
your idea does work better than my idea
you know and so we we took that idea and
incorporated it into the film so i'm not
so much about
um
being so vain as to say my way is the
only way but i believe there should be
one voice
that one voice should ring very clear
throughout the film and along the way
because it's a collaborative process
there'll be times when someone will have
advice for you that really
makes that moment way more honest
than the one you created
and you have to take that advice as the
voice you know that that advice is good
sound advice
but it can't just be shoved into the
film because
this guy said so
because it can really take people out of
the film
how many screenplays have you written
i have lost count
i have lost count um
more than 50
more than 50. i can say that
feature screenplays or a mixture of
shorts and features
um no those are those will be all
features mixture features mixture of
pilots you know
when did you write your first feature
screenplay
maybe about
18 19
and it was
it was called audacious
what's the name of it and nobody
understood like what is this and i had
to explain what audacious meant and
uh
but it was a vampire script yeah
oh okay and you were in georgia at the
time i was in georgia yeah okay and i i
think at that time i hadn't learned the
importance of of titles you know titles
have to be strong and understandable
and have sometimes a couple of different
meanings
you know they can't just be
self-indulgent
you know
and uh everything i wrote had some
weird thing that i'd learned
um
but that was by far the weirdest title i
think i came up with which was audacious
what does it actually mean to live
vicariously through someone or something
like a parasite oh okay yeah interesting
codependency yeah oh okay okay
and that's really what it was about
about this vampire needing this guy to
come to fruition you know
to come to be
what was your writing process like on
that first screenplay
making sure
uh
that the names were indented properly
and you know making sure spacing was
appropriate and the proper font was
being used i was it was so much still a
learning process of just what went into
writing us a screenplay
um
from a
formatting standpoint not a story
structure standpoint
so at that point i hadn't even gotten
into
really into the craft
it was still very much just how do i
make this look professional
so
how long did it take you to finish that
screenplay oh
five days
oh wow okay five days in the beginning i
wrote screenplays
in a week or less
in a week because i didn't know what i
didn't know
like once you understand what the craft
really is and how you
how you get how you move an audience the
way you need to move them how do you get
out information without it being very
convoluted or heavy-handed how do you
how do you get information across both
in text and subtext like once you start
getting into that and story structure
it's
it complicates things and there's no way
that you're writing a script in a week
and if you do
and it reads very well i'm i'm impressed
i'm impressed because there's a lot of
work that goes into it
just in terms of just outlining takes me
about a week or more
just outlining it just to understand
what's going on in a very like one page
kind of way it takes a while so back
then i didn't know that so you when you
don't know what you don't know you just
you plow right through it like i'm done
you drop it on the desk
and for some reason i think i think it's
all because the industry was so new to
georgia in the in the late 90s
you know early 2000s like late 90s
really and that's where i really started
to
you know get a lot of work and i'm
turning in and stuff
that agent i don't i knew that he'd
certainly
represented other writers and
but i don't i don't think he ever
represented anybody who was
successful
because there's no way you could if you
were receiving those kind of screenplays
and just being like whoa
that's awesome it's there is no
structure i look back sometimes on some
of the things i've written like what was
i thinking and it's just because you you
didn't know
you don't know what you don't know
and so you're you're constantly learning
every time and especially when you seek
knowledge and you you don't have
that vanity to believe that you're the
best at something
i never believe that i'm the best at
anything other than being me that that's
really it and i'm even sometimes
struggling with that right
so so i'm constantly looking at ways to
improve and as i began to understand
story structure and stuff like that my
stories got better but it took a while
for me to get to the place where i am
now where i feel
i feel
as though
i'm creating very
um
complete stories
you know where you don't feel at the end
like what no i'm just missing something
i just can't figure out what it is you
know i feel like my stories are very
complete now i feel they tell a complete
story
and
all the arcs are completed and they're
completed skillfully
i'm always just looking to
figure out how to write a better
script the next time how do i how do i
write a better script the next time
and then i start okay i did this last
time
what do i improve but what didn't i know
that i know now and
you know and that's how you continue to
grow
but back then
script in a week was nothing
do you think it would have helped if you
had this delusion where you thought your
thing was the greatest or your writing
was the greatest you know some people
they're able to convince everybody to
that somehow i don't know i know people
like that i know people like that and
and don't get me wrong i don't mean i
know people like that who don't work i
know people like that who are working
and some of the conversations i've heard
have been hilarious
because this person
has i think in the arts because it is
it is so much it is so personal even if
it's supposed to be business it's really
personal
you create something it came from you
you birthed it right
and then you hear somebody look at two
pages and go that's garbage what else
you got
you you either have to be able to accept
it
and say that's not for them
or
you become calloused and you become
you develop a sense of an inflated ego
and i think that if you if you develop
the inflated ego which i think is the
go-to
you
you start stunting your growth as a
matter of fact i'd venture to say you
start regressing
because when the going gets tough you're
gonna fall back on the things you know
and you've never bothered to learn
anything new you're just gonna fall back
on the things that you think have worked
and
i see that a lot in the industry i don't
think that's helpful at all i think i
think it's to your detriment oh and when
i say detriment i don't mean detriment
in terms of of your your marketability i
i mean in terms of your true ability to
grow and become your best you i think
it's i think it's uh it's detrimental
with autism did you ever try to sell it
yes
sadly
the the agent did try to sell it and you
know he tried very hard and i don't
blame anybody from not for not buying it
as a matter of fact
i have told this to
uh
everyone including my mom who thinks i'm
the absolute best i told my mom i'm
absolutely
over the moon that nobody took me
seriously in the beginning
because if they had and i had made any
of the number of screenplays that i had
written in the in the past in my in the
very beginning
they would have laughed me out of here
and i would have never got another job
i think i would have never reached a
point where i felt as though i could
take you know my career into my own
hands i never would have gotten there
because i think at that age if that
happens to you you're done
i think you're done
if somebody if somebody cuts your legs
off at 20
i think your legs are just gone
i think you don't have the stomach for
it i see too many people that come to la
and they think they're gonna be
and then they get their legs cut out
from under them and they go back to
where they came from
and they are no longer interested in the
business at all
so i'm very fortunate that nobody took
me serious except that one agent
very serious i mean
i think everything happened exactly how
it was supposed to
i on the one assignment that i was sent
out on and taken seriously and it was
through a sample not from me
writing anything for that specific pilot
it was just from a sample of my writing
in general and that's how i was on you
know young americans but
if it had can you imagine if i if they
have wanted a submission like so a tv
show i've written and i submitted
something it was like yeah here take a
look at this
get out of here
that's what would have happened it was
too green
i didn't know enough
so
can you take us all the way through your
writing process
um
it's changed a lot
before i think my writing process was
more
i had an idea and then
i wanted to
take a really good look at the two main
characters and then branch off from
there with and i would always write like
random
scenes like these are the must
you know half scenes in the script
because that's what ultimately made me
think about the the
the story
i carried that with me for a while
but now
it's not so much that and it's because
i've i've made enough films where i know
what goes into making one and just
starting at the writing standpoint
so now i only write stories that wake me
up in the middle of the night and make
me go grab my laptop if it doesn't make
me do that i don't write it
if there's something that happens and
i'm like you know what that's it i i
gotta sit down i gotta nail this
and the reason is because you know as
we've spoken about before that passion
if
if what you
have in here isn't
it it doesn't wake you up in the middle
of the night with for this project
then i don't know how possible it is
like you're gonna have to fight so hard
to make it to the end
so
for me it starts with
does this thing wake me up in the middle
of the night is this the only thing i
can think about right now
and if it is the only thing i can think
about what am i thinking about right now
why do i want to write this what is it
saying about me and i start with that
and then what i do
is ultimately
something is going on around me that's
making me feel this way and oftentimes
it's music
so then that song is on repeat repeat
repeat repeat i'm writing a story right
now called uh moon and the stars
and
it's a story about love but not romantic
love i mean there's romantic love in it
but it's it's more about the real
concept of love like when you really
love someone what you're willing to do
for them what does it really mean for
you to really love someone
and
uh believe it or not
the
i can't get this story out of my head
and i'm already we've already set it up
to start production in 2022
the song that i have on repeat is what
is a guy's name
weekend
and his song save your tears i don't
know if you've heard that song but i
just have it on repeat and i just write
and i write and i write i'm just so
obsessed with the story i'm so obsessed
with the character's journey and
at every time i stop because i always
say you know find the perfect scene and
stop
and then when i stop i go back and i
think about all the technical stuff you
know and i start to make notes for
myself okay when you go back to rewrite
make sure you think about this and think
about this and think about this
and then when i sit down the next day to
write it that song goes on and by the
way i don't know if this is a thing for
every song but on youtube
you can search the song and
loop and then it'll come up with
somebody who's made like a two hour loop
of the same song over and over and over
and i just hit play and i just
and i just i and i know what the
objective is for every scene
so i sit down i'm looking through my
notes i'm like okay this is my objective
for today i need to do this for these
previous scenes and then the new scenes
have to be about this
it has to be a point to every scene i
can't just sit down like i did before
and just write a scene and hopefully
some way find some sort of connect you
know some kind of connective tissue for
the rest of the story i have to know the
point of the scene and who's making the
point and why is this person the best
person to make this point
or why is this event the event that
needs to happen now
you know and i that's how i kind of
structure each scene
but i go back and make sure it fits the
story as a whole and i just do that all
the way
through when you say that you you what
if it wakes you up in the middle of the
night are you already up for something
else and then you're like you know what
this one part i've just gotta write this
down or how does that work if let's say
it's two in the morning on a tuesday and
you just happen to wake up
what's your process are you going to a
laptop
it all depends it all depends uh if i am
trying to
not wake up
the cat or my wife you know
then it's going to be going into the
into the living room where you know my
office is and you know sitting down at
the computer and just you know but then
there'll be times where maybe i get hit
with inspiration at 6 00 a.m 6 a.m and
the sun's probably starting to come up
it's okay if i grab the laptop and
you know from the bed
you know so i'll do it that way but but
usually i feel something and i have to
get up and i have to write and i have to
complete this script
you know and it happens
it only happens when now because
i think i've
i've allowed myself to
surrender to whatever
that that thing is inside you that
intuition it tells you now is a time
i think that it's well somebody someone
said a while back where you know writing
is a profession
and
you have to sit down at the keyboard at
a certain time and then you get up from
that computer at a certain time because
it's your job to write it's your career
and you're professional
that's okay i i get that i get that but
if you are a person who you have
multiple films in various stages of
production
maybe nine to five isn't something i can
do because i'm still editing this one
i'm still handling the promotional stuff
for this one i'm doing interviews over
here for that one
i can't just sit at a computer from nine
to five right
so i write when the inspiration hits me
and oftentimes it is in the middle of
the night it's it's in that moment where
you
you kind of wake up or you're about to
go to sleep that little that little area
i don't know what it is about that time
but it's like oh
there it is and then you just
and you punch you know you you sit there
and you punch the keypad until you get
it out of your system you purge out of
your system and you go back and you you
read it and you make sure you got
everything okay i get everything okay
cool let me write my notes and that's
just my notes for what to do when i come
back to it
and how does it tie back into the rest
of the story just making sure that it
stays fresh because when you get that
feeling
and you put it on paper you sometimes
forget
certain details
so you make sure i make sure i want to
write it down and then i go back
but yeah i believe that you you have to
surrender to that
that urge
that desire to get up right now
because you you you feel that this needs
to be on the page at this moment i don't
believe that's something you can force
my best writing has been when i felt
that urge
are you sensitive to the moon
i don't know oh okay because you used
it's called moon and stars or whatever
oh it's moon m-u-n-e and stars
s-t-a-r-r-s okay and uh
it's
really affecting you yeah no no no it's
funny it's it's uh it's a story that
when i describe it people go well
where's the love story but it's it's a
story about this um
1842
um
this child she's 66 years old
six-year-old prodigy from beijing
and she's
taken through a portal
by this guy named igoon and the order of
fanu
and they take her to a place where
love wilts and hope goes to die
and
they take her here and then the story
picks up in this day and age
and
there's a guy who's going through a
breakup and he's trying desperately to
get back with his fiance
and
he's been having his vision since he was
a kid of you know
various
catastrophes and this one girl is always
in his dreams and
one day
when he's
just at his bottom
the portal opens up and she comes
through
and she tells him that he's the only
like the ego and the order for new are
coming to basically destroy life as we
know it and you are the only hope
and
the guy who's had no desire to do
anything in his life other than be with
this woman over here
now has a new mission in life
and ultimately
the woman that he is in love with who
just doesn't want to be with him right
now
she's also enlisted to help him in this
fight to save the universe
and
throughout all of it what he has to
learn
is
what what is love truly because love he
thought was showing someone how much
you want to be with them so they'll want
to be with you
but truly it's it's having enough
love for this person to only want the
best for them even if the best for them
isn't you
you know
that's all you want is you want to see
the best for this person and that's the
lesson that he's trying to learn
throughout this movie and that's
ultimately the lesson that helps him
to be successful at saving the world in
the universe
wow
but in all of that that just came from
i don't know what it was it was
something happened and it just made me
evaluate love and what we think of it as
as people even healthy people like what
we think about love and i was just like
man so many people have it so backwards
so backwards
they or they love a person because of
how the person makes them feel and it's
like that's not love that's
you know it's something
but it ain't love
um
and that's that's what really wakes me
up is you know whenever i find some
other example of it and i'm like oh
why isn't that in the script
and then it's like oh and then this
person does this and this event happens
and i'm just constantly jumping up in
the middle of the night or early morning
and plugging in more pages
and
it's all coming from a place of
of uh passion but also truth and and
honesty which i believe truth and
honesty are two very different things
but um
you know it's coming from a place of
truth in a place of honesty and
and uh building this story and those are
the stories that i'm trying to tell now
versus how i used to tell stories i used
to tell stories it was very stream of
consciousness and it was whatever it was
supposed to be and then it was done and
now i put more thought into making sure
the stories are just honest they're
coming from an honest place even if you
don't agree
with the message even if you don't agree
with the characters it's coming from a
place of honesty
yeah i was wondering what what is the
difference between writing honesty and
writing truth in your screenplay um i
think truth is a fact honesty is the
feeling
i think honesty is your intent
okay if you i met many people who are
super honest but their facts are so
screwed up that is not the truth that is
not what happened
but you can tell a person truth and not
be honest also you can tell facts and
omit certain things that don't fit your
narrative and that's being dishonest yet
you're still being truthful
okay so
which would you rather have in a story
truth or honesty
honesty
i think
i think honesty inner story is is better
than the truth
but i i aspire to have both
what has to happen in the first 10
minutes of a horror screenplay
i think it depends on the genre
and what you're trying to accomplish
but i think certainly
there should be something that happens
in that first 10 minutes that makes an
audience realize holy crap i'm in for a
ride
something has to happen in that first 10
minutes that gives you that feeling and
if that doesn't happen i i
i will often times wonder what we were
waiting on
that's just like some a friend of mine
he gets onto me because he's way bigger
filming tv buff than i am
and
he always says to me like oh you stopped
watching the tv show too soon it got
really good on the fifth episode and i'm
like then why did they wait into the
fifth episode
do it from the beginning
i do this for a living you can do it
do it from the beginning i think it
works the same way with with horror
films if in the first 10 minutes you've
you've not told the audience what kind
of ride they're on
then you in my book you haven't
succeeded in my book you're setting
yourself up to fail
so in the first 10 minutes give them
something give them something to realize
holy crap something's about to go down
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
um a gory scene it's just maybe a sense
of mystery a sense of something
ominous that's looming yeah i just mean
give them that's why i say depends on
the type of film that it is
because there can be it can be a film
that is going to make you feel so
uncomfortable so they give you something
at the beginning to let you know
like what's happening or what the stakes
are or something
something that really pulls you in and
lets you know like i really need to keep
watching this film
if you haven't given him the hook like
what's gonna pull them in i don't i
don't know what you're doing really and
that goes really not even just for for
horror films but films in general
i think you should give somebody some
indication of of what kind of ride
they're on
is it going to be the the disney tea
cups that spin around is it going to be
you know space mountain what kind of
ride are we on you know
so with 70s and 80s horror you think we
took our time really
making it a little more eerie a little
more suspenseful
i think
people cared more
there is
there's this thing that happens when you
shoot film where everybody goes hey this
is serious you know
and
i feel
that's lost now
i feel like people say you know if we
don't get it right we'll get it again
we'll do it again and we'll do it again
we'll do it again nobody takes it really
as serious but even right now if you
tell somebody we're shooting 35
millimeter film and you show up and you
plop down the film camera everybody goes
hey hey this is serious
and everybody starts taking way more so
i don't know what it is about a film
camera that makes everything more
serious
but it does
and i think back then that was all you
had you only had film it was just what
kind of film are you gonna shoot with
but you only had film
and so everybody took everything very
serious and and then two if you were a
small production you had a limited
amount of film
most of the time you were shooting with
a bunch of short ends whatever
it was very serious and it was very well
thought out and nothing was shot in an
extraneous sense
nothing was shot just in case everything
was shot with a purpose
and uh
you know i think we're missing that
today
is that why you love the 80s horror
genre oh
i love it for so many reasons but that's
one of them
that's one of them
um i certainly i felt there was a magic
in the 80s
you know i felt i mean it came in at the
late 70s as well but but there was just
a certain magic with the 80s and the way
the films entertained while still taking
it all very seriously
and and still really focusing on on the
creative and technical aspects but just
really putting that production value out
there making it feel magical making it
feel special um
i i feel like that's
that's something that i i've carried
with me in in all of my films trying to
make something special always
even when it's a shoestring budget i've
tried to find some sort of way
are there five 80s horror films or late
70s horror films that you think every
horror filmmaker should watch like
you know salem slide or or you know any
of these stephen king
um
i mean
my favorite is one that
you know when people hear it they kind
of go what is that but
uh evil dead trap i think everybody
should see that i wanted to say it was i
don't know when that one came out i know
it was in the
mid to late 80s
and
it is a completely insane horror film
from japan
and it was at a time when those movies
were banned especially ones that were
this that depicted violence and gore to
this extent i mean this guy
went hard
core
okay
and i remember seeing that in where did
i see that film i don't even know where
i saw it it's such such a rare film i
forget where i saw it but
i fell in love with it immediately and
i've watched it i don't know how many
times i had to buy it and the only way
you could buy it in the u.s
was part of a a big pack of films where
it was evil dead trap because that's the
only one i really really watch and then
it was another one called like entrails
of a virgin
oh yeah yeah um it's just
they're so bizarre
but yet you could tell when the film is
made it's made with love
this guy loved the genre
he loved this was before gore gross out
was a thing
before you know gore it was you know
people think about like the mutilator
that movie and
which
not a great movie but the thing about it
was was you know it had some decent gore
and the positions that they put people
in even when they didn't show it when it
was just implied you were like ah you
know
um but nobody had taken it to the extent
that this guy did
you know i think his name is was it
toshi toshiharu ikita is his name
and uh the visuals of that movie are
just so disturbing
um
but
i look at that film as being my top
horror film
uh ones that influenced me yes
now if you start getting into others
that people should see
do you mean like top hard top just films
in general it's all hard because it just
seemed like there was a creepiness
factor that really took time to build
yeah and and i really love that of the
that era not so much the gore
yeah absolutely this one had this one
had the gore came in much later
but it did have the the creepy effect
speaking of evil dead trap it did it if
you haven't seen it please see it it's
i endorse this film okay my name is
josten yes and i approve this message um
now if you're if you're moving away from
that you have to like right next to that
put halloween the original halloween now
that one is not 80s that one's late 70s
i think that's like 78 or 79
um
but that's what i meant by late 70s
early 80s you know that time period
so i would definitely put halloween on
that list i think they they got busy
quick they let you knew let they let you
know what type of movie you were in uh
they had a summer camp feel but in
someone's house which was pretty easy i
mean pretty interesting i i really loved
that about the film um i think he took
his time
and he didn't try to rush anything in
the film but you understood in that
first 10 minutes what kind of movie you
were watching it wasn't a mystery
it wasn't a mystery
um i think once you once you leave that
one
i want to i want to stay more
in the more accessible range so i would
say if i if i'm going with what's more
accessible i would then lean towards
your
uh your hellraisers i think hellraiser
was very creative for his time
um
i don't think anybody really kind of got
into that aspect yet of making your
making who would normally be a villain
kind of an anti-hero
so i thought that was pretty cool that
was pretty clever
um
and from there i jump into to your your
jason's and your freddie kruegers
yeah
what about the use i don't know if this
would be horror tropes but you know
let's say the the late night phone call
and no one's there yeah like what what
are some of the things that are just
tried and true that they always work it
doesn't matter
what year this is just it just builds an
intrigue
um i think that shot from behind
when a person is walking through a house
and the camera is drifting behind them
and then they stop and the camera's
slowly getting closer
okay because you're like oh my god
what's gonna happen you know i think
that always works and that never gets
old and nobody ever says why you know
that's tired nobody ever says that
because it's just the movement of a
camera i think once you get into actions
that's where it gets
you know kind of tropey
i think when you get into the late night
phone call i think when you get into the
um oh my gosh it's so hot let me take my
clothes off
and then you see the hand reach in and
take the clothes away and it's like oh
that's not the killer that's their
friend you know this is like oh come on
you know like a lot of those things i i
think they get really tropey but i think
the
the camera tricks are the things that
don't get old i don't like the jumpy
things i don't really like those so much
those are boring to me mainly because i
don't jump but um
i i like to be creeped out i like to end
the movie and like go should i turn off
the light you know
i want that feeling
but i think
the whole camera moving behind someone i
love rosemary's baby when the camera
kind of shifts a little
and you're constantly thinking
something's about to happen to her just
because the camera moved a little i like
little subtle things like that
i think those are still very effective
they'll never go away
should something scary happen on page
one of a horror film or is it better to
wait a little bit
if it fits the story
it's all about what fits the story
and what story you're trying to tell
if um
if you get right to it on page one hey
bravo i hope that you don't take your
foot off the gas because
now you've built up expectation
because i think you said in the last
question that halloween they let you
know fairly quickly
what was going on
is that something that did they maintain
it it's been a while sorry so oh yeah
but but mainly because halloween wasn't
it wasn't a story about a guy in a mask
who was just killing people
at random like that wasn't the story
um it was a story of evil and evil
started young and this kid was full of
evil and so
as he when he grew up and he came home
it was like what is this guy going to do
now
you know and he was stalking jamie lee's
curtis character and you always knew it
was that it was that that sense of it
did you ever see uh what was that movie
uh it follows
and it was you know the girl
has sex with the guy and then
the evil spirit starts following her and
if it catches her it'll kill her that
sort of thing right
so the thing about it was it moved slow
but it was always present and it was
always closing in so even if it was far
behind
you knew you had to stay that much ahead
of it right you knew
in this movie jamie lee curtis didn't
know only the audience knew
that he was closing in on her he's
getting closer and closer and close and
that's where the dread came from that's
why in the beginning of the film
when we see him as a kid and we see him
like he's actually going about murdering
you know his sister and the sister's
boyfriend and all that stuff
it was the build up of this evil that
was inside this kid and he slowly worked
his way up to that in those first 10
minutes right
and then he grew up and now you're
watching it play out as an adult so he
he built he set the tone for what the
rest of the film was going to be and he
didn't really let up all he did was give
you someone to care about in jamie lee
curtis's character laurie strode he gave
you somebody to care about and then he
said now watch me butcher her and then
you were like you were so worried for it
you were like please
run
he's right there you know
and i think he did that very very well
sure and it would be the same i guess in
the exorcist as well even though the
character wasn't stalking her it was
inside of her and she couldn't she
couldn't get it out she couldn't stop it
yeah
you set the tone very early with that
one i mean they said an eerie tone uh
when they were digging up they're
excavating the thing and it was it just
felt weird the musical cues the zooms
all of it felt weird all of it felt very
very weird and they kept that feeling
throughout it just kept you off balance
it kept you really off balance it made
your skin crawl a little bit
right yeah
it was great
how often have you read a screenplay
where nothing happens in the first 10
minutes
no scares nothing all too often
all too often
um
i think that
because
the software now can format things for
you and everybody learns about final
draft or or
movie magic or whatever they learn about
these these different
programs
it's easy to make your screenplay look
professional
it's only when you
start to read it do you do you
understand
the level of craft that they're at right
now
right and in certain levels of craft
there's always that oh we're building to
something great we're building to
something great and that's at a certain
level right
and they may be
really you know really good at crafting
a story and dialogue and
things may seem okay
but if nothing is happening and nothing
is happening by page 10 nothing is
happening by page 15 but page 20 when is
something gonna happen
i do i do read a lot of scripts where i
wonder that or i wonder what is the
point
what is the point what are you trying to
say
even if you have nothing to say
what is the point of the film
who's your hero what is this person
going through
how does going through this change them
how does going through this and them
changing
help them deal with the true protect
antagonist
you know all those things all those
questions they aren't answered because
they aren't at that level yet
you know so
you're gonna get a mismatch but for the
most part i would say out of
if i read
10 screenplays
something happens by page 10
in one of them depending upon which week
it is
not every time does something happen
not all the time does it
sometimes it might be one of the 20
screenplays
what if someone says well i want to take
my time with the suspense i mean if you
look back at the step for wives and i
realize that's not really horror it's
more like thriller
it was a long intro
to them coming to this new neighborhood
and seeing these wives and
and she's kind of confused about what's
going on i mean it took its time yeah
but the thing about it is it establishes
its tone very quickly
and i feel like that's another thing
that's missing because so many people
haven't found their voice
how they tell a story right
because your story may change depending
upon
whatever genre you've decided to write
today whatever
got into you like
this love story that i wanted that i'm
writing right now moon in the stars it's
it's a it's people hear me say it's a
love story and you think oh romantic
drama and i'm like actually no it's a
sci-fi it's a sci-fi these people are uh
interstellar travelers interdimensional
travelers time travelers and they can do
this and they can do that and like but
then where's the love portion well the
love portions here and it's but it's a
completely different thing than i've
ever written
once in one is a very completely
different story than i've ever written i
think that people classify that one as a
suspense drama or drama thriller or
something like that
so and that's very different than the
horror that i've directed and even
within the horror i've directed many
different types of horror
so
no matter what the genre is that you're
writing in you have to at some point
have developed your voice
and how how how a person recognizes that
it's your film
right
and then once you start to develop your
voice i think it'll help you drastically
with maintaining tone of a film
because your voice is your voice and
it's how you tell the story and as long
as you understand the tone of your own
film you can keep that modulated all the
way through and you can set that at the
very beginning then once you set that
tone like this is where this story takes
place in this type of world
you start that from page one
you start it from page one
so yes
nothing may happen in terms of
someone getting murdered or whatever you
may not get the horror in the because it
may not be a horror maybe it's just a
movie that's meant to make you squirm
and make you uncomfortable
maybe that's what it is or maybe the
story is speaking to um like with once
and one it was about a guy who didn't
even know himself anymore so if he
doesn't know himself he doesn't even
recognize himself in certain situations
and if you tell him he's done something
wrong
he's relying on your truth to tell him
he's done something wrong because he
doesn't even know right and wrong of
himself anymore and i showed that from
page one
if you can't even recognize
who you are and what you do in the
situation when someone tells you to make
it better how can you he's like how do i
how do i do it and the person has to
tell him i think that's something you
can figure out and he's like
well i don't think he can
he really can't it sets the tone for the
film nobody died
you know
nobody was hunted down in the first 10
pages i just set the tone for for what
the story is
and i think that that's
you know once you it takes a while
before you get to that level of
understanding of of what you're doing
and then i think
now you've gotten to a point where
technically you're proficient
you know but you still have so much more
like so many more levels to climb
you know
do you think it's better that someone
rushes into
a more of a horrific scene or takes
their time like which which is more
detrimental to a horror script too long
to get into the action or too fast
i mean again i i think it depends on the
the point of the story
i think that
scream which is
one of my faves from the 90s
it in the first film
it kind of meanders right at first
in the first like minute or two she
picks up the phone she's talking to the
guy
and making popcorn everything seems fine
it seems very casual
it's not until the first kind of slip up
that she doesn't hear that we heard is
the audience that we realize wait a
minute and then you start to
you start to sit forward right
the story is about a guy
who calls you on the phone he stabs you
to death
we didn't see that until like it came in
probably around the five minute mark is
when we started to be concerned
right
so in that first five minutes it's like
are we just following this lady and if
you notice that movie is
really for the longest time it's a
single shot
it's a single shot she picks up the
phone and they pull away from the phone
they're following her around into the
kitchen it's a single shot for a lot of
it
and even when they abandon it they pick
it up on another another winner and
they're walking around and it's
masterfully done
but it's all about the pacing and the
tone
and it slowly becomes more menacing
and once it becomes menacing it never
lets up
and so again less about dialogue and
more about camera movement camera
movement and just
really understanding tone i think you
know lighting plays an incredible
cinematography in general plays an
incredible uh role in creating tone your
cinematography your editing
post-production sound musical cues sound
effect all that stuff plays a huge role
in it but when you're reading it on the
page when you're on the page
it has something has to set the tone for
me to understand
why i should care
and a lot of the times i ask
why should i care very early i'll ask
that on page sometimes too i'll ask why
should i care now something may not
happen until page three or page four
but i'll be asking myself why do i care
when i watch movies at home i'll turn
them on
i'll watch for a little bit but then
i'll turn it because there's so much
content that's available right now
why would i waste time i treat a movie
that i'm watching just like i would a
script that i'm reading i start watching
and if it's not catching my attention i
have to abandon
i have to abandon it yeah i think it was
harder before because there was so
little
you couldn't check a phone
you couldn't have one window open and be
over here you had to you were just like
all right i'll let it play
and sometimes that worked with advantage
because then it grew on you but now
you have to catch people that's what i
was asking if you knew the analytics of
when people dropped out or if people
rewound a scene or something yeah i
don't have it like in terms of analytics
from from
amazon i don't i don't have it when
someone
maybe
rewinds it or something i don't have
that but i do know
i can tell
the progression like
people are dropping out dropping out
dropping out dropping out oh it
stabilized and then people watched it
all the way through here and then it
dropped out like i can tell that you
know but i can't really tell
did they pause it and then go do
something and come back like i can't
tell those sort of things or that they
rewind you can't really see that
but
the the thing about it is is that i
usually will start my films
and i try to get them to a point where
you don't
feel there's a place to jump off because
something's always building to something
else
and one scene leads into the next very
naturally so i'm constantly trying to do
that so it doesn't feel like there's a
place to really drop off or you'll feel
like you're missing something because
something just happened so now i have to
see how that affects the next thing i'm
constantly trying to to keep that
momentum going and i think that's what
you you have to do or what you should
aspire to do
when you're doing anything
something it always has to be building
towards something or what else are we
doing
why why would i be investing my time if
if nothing in your script is investing
towards something bigger
so a bigger character goal or a bigger
scare or or something with the
antagonist
yeah set up your stakes
um
give me a character who's who's
interesting that i care about
um even if you don't want to root for
them to succeed root for them to not
succeed
something give the audience something to
to to
to keep them invested and keep them
interested and
it does start with having something in
the first few pages whether it's tone
whether it's an act of
whatever that drives the story forward
give them something that keeps them
watching more importantly something that
lets them know what kind of a ride
they're on
sure because even with hereditary we
didn't totally know we just knew
something ominous yes was there and it
kind of keeps you on the edge
and you didn't know what was it though
you know yeah and the great thing about
hereditary right now is if if you if we
talk about hereditary the first thing we
do is go you know hereditary you know we
went just thinking about it right
but if you if you go back and you think
like what do i remember from the film i
remember
there was this like little sibling thing
with the brother and the sister i
remember her head hit that pole
and it came off
and then i remember he didn't want to
like he just parked the car and went
into the house
i remember the thing from him in the
classroom where his face kind of
you know went crazy and he slammed his
head on the desk and stuff i remember
that and then i remember all the stuff
that happened at the end with him
you know with the mother and the father
bursting into flames and all that stuff
and the mom banging her head
but we're recalling just these few
moments but the fact is
is that we made it to the end in
complete terror because of the tone of
the film
the tone was set very early and they
never let up
even when they had moments where it
looked like hope was starting to shine
in through the window
it didn't matter the tone was so dark
and ominous and heavy
that you just you felt like oh and you
felt cold i don't know if about you i
felt cold watching it you know
it was it was such a weird feeling that
you got watching that movie but they
kept that tone up throughout the entire
film and that's what i mean is it's
finding your tone and staying with it
very early something that makes people
care and make them keep watching
how much punishment should we put our
main character through
well i think
somebody described it best when they
said the what you do to make someone
what a story is is
people chasing a character up a tree and
throwing rocks at them while they're
trying to climb down
that's ultimately what a story is right
and so i think that you should put them
through as much
punishment
as they can
weather
and still
uh
realistically want to pursue their goal
and still realistically understand the
stakes
you know
uh
one of my favorite shows is the walking
dead right
and there was a period in episode oh in
season
seven was it seven or eight
may have been season seven
and people kind of stopped watching
it went like this and mainly it was due
to
how much punishment they put the main
character through
he
had so much punishment heaped upon him
that his only goal
was not to receive more punishment
that his people would receive no more
punishment
and this was from a character who had
been a a world beater for
six seasons
you know and all of a sudden we're
watching him not only be beaten but to
just be beaten to a point where the
fight is beaten out of them
and i think people jumped off because
that was the point that the punishment
went too far
that was the point where audience was
like okay i'm tapping out i can't do it
anymore
there was there was i remember there was
an episode where he just stood there
like it was just one locked off shot of
him
and he just cried and the camera went to
a wide shot and he's just completely
alone and he's crying and there's a guy
who
you know he just watched be killed that
was from his community and the guy turns
into a zombie so it's even worse now
he's had a freaking after he just
witnessed this happen to the guy and he
could do nothing about it he had to turn
around and be the person to
you know
right through the brain to put him out
of his misery like i i think
you know i still kept watching of course
because it's one of my favorite shows
but i can understand why people jumped
off because at that point punishment
went too far
so
you know i think it's
it's it has to be enough punishment
where
it does create the wound that we're all
looking for him to heal
but it can't be so much that if
it makes him forget
the goal
the goal was not to not to receive more
punishment the goal was to keep his
people safe and get rid of all
threats
and now he's not trying to get rid of
the threat he's trying to live with the
threat and he fears the threat
and i think that's too much for
audiences to to deal with we have to
constantly keep this guy moving forward
and working towards his goal while all
the time realizing he could probably
lose
he could probably lose but will root for
him if he keeps pursuing his goal
so it was the fact that we saw the fight
beaten out of him
not the that not him being put through
the fight
well he there was no fight he was being
punished and punished and punished and
punished
it was it was so have you seen this uh
seasons if you haven't seen season seven
it's it starts with him on his knees
because that's how the season
six ended with him on his knees so it
starts with him on his knees
and watching two of his friends and he
could do nothing about it they're told
if you move
we'll kill everybody but for right now
we're just gonna kill this one guy in
front of you all
and they proceed to beat this guy's head
in with a baseball bat
in front of
all his friends
and another guy can't take it anymore he
gets up and hits the bad guy and the bad
guy says that's going to cost you
because now i'm going to beat another
guy
head in and he beats another guy's head
in all the while the leader has to watch
this happen and he can do nothing
he starts the season on his knees
watching his friends die and there's
nothing he can do
and then for the rest of that season
he's met with even more punishment and
more punishment and the threat is always
if you don't do what we say and you
don't give us what we want we'll show up
and kill everybody don't forget that
and it's like how many times can you see
that and how many times can you see that
and the good guy
not say
that's it we got to come up with a plan
his only plan is to make sure there's
not more punishment
you can't you can't do that to audiences
they have to see the fight they have to
see the struggle they have to see you
trying to win
not being complacent with
being proud beaten you know
would you say the more punishment we put
our protagonist through the better the
story is going to be to a certain extent
yes
to a certain extent as long as we don't
put them through too much
i think that we have to see
i mean for my stories i love to
to to show the person show their wound
and then show how they've begin to live
with this wound by accepting it as a
truth even though it's a false truth
and how their world is with that right
now this person may not be down on their
luck or anything but something has
happened and this is told them that this
is the way you live life right and there
has to be something that forces them on
their journey
when they start going on their journey
they can't win every little
battle they gotta lose but they gotta
see that you know what but i can see on
the other side of it if i just keep
going because this these are the stakes
and i can't allow myself to lose
they have to take enough punishment
along the way
where you
you keep believing in them even if they
don't they don't really believe in
themselves
and then it has to get to a point where
it's a soul-crushing defeat like right
when they thought they won it's a
soul-crushing defeat
and you got to watch them pick up the
pieces and you got to fill you got to
that's when you you know circle the
wagons and you know you're bringing
together all the different people that
are gonna help you build build the
character back up and put them back on
their their journey because now they
realize this is the worst that it can
get
you know this is the worst that this guy
can do to me but the stakes are still
the stakes i still have to stop this
thing from happening whatever it is
right so they've absorbed all this
punishment and they realize that's the
worst that it can get
so
this guy cannot hurt me any more than
this only by them succeeding at their
goal
so now i'm just going to go straight
after them straight away now there's
many different ways of what you can do
to get them to stop the bad guy or the
bad guy succeeds or whatever but
at this point that's when the audience
is behind them they receive enough
punishment where
they have
hopefully
garnered the sympathy of the audience
and the audience is behind them so that
when they lead them into this final
battle
the audience is right behind them right
on the horse right behind them like oh
you know and you're you're watching this
person go in and save the day
now
if you give them too much punishment i
think the audience can bail
because they're just i've seen it happen
they just bailed i don't think you can
watch a person just lose
you know i don't think you can watch
them just lose
they have to have some win somewhere
what are ways that a writer can create
high stakes for their character ooh
it's a good question um
it has to be well first of all it has to
be something that relates to their wound
right it has to be some
kink in their armor where
this makes it personal for them
it has to be that that's number one
and because overall the story is about
them overcoming that wound and that's
somehow tying into
this goal of stopping whatever the
antagonist is
so but the stakes have to be high enough
where it almost seems insurmountable
you know so yeah i believe that you know
the stakes are very important but it has
to be all relatable to the character
into the audience
okay so
if it's something that's too avant-garde
we can't understand it but if it's just
sort of about the basic needs of living
safety security then we can relate to it
i think it can be
almost anything it all depends on who
you are who your core audience is
um
for
just giving example for once and one
right if you if you watch the film it's
it's very easy to sit back and go i what
i don't really get it but the story is
very meta it's it's very meta this
there's a story happening
and then there's a story that the writer
is writing
but unbeknownst to him
they both are the same story
okay
and in the story that he's trying to
write that he's having writer's block
with the reason why he can't relate is
because he's
cut so many pieces of himself away to
fit in right to fit in with
this life with his wife this new
hollywood life
he was doing it before when he was
trying to do sales he's just trying to
fit in with everybody with his friends
he keeps cutting off pieces of himself
to the point where he doesn't recognize
himself anymore okay and he's not honest
with himself
without honesty and he doesn't know
himself he doesn't even know what he
wants
he's writing a script that he can't
he can't finish it it seems convoluted
there's all this other stuff going on
inside the story that he's writing is
about a guy who's robbing a bank
he wants the money
then there's his girl that he meets
inside of the bank he starts falling for
the girl there's the police outside the
police are going to make him pay for
whatever he does right
if he
wants the girl he has to give up the
money because she doesn't like stealing
and all that other kind of stuff
if he takes the money he loses the girl
and all of that the police are still
outside how is he going to get past that
in both of these stories it's not even
knowing what the guy wants
the guy doesn't know what he wants he's
all over the place right
and what you begin to realize is for the
protagonist and the story
his wife
is
really related to the money in the story
that's his security
he's so secure with his wife because
she's on a sole property she makes lots
of money
he can be a struggling writer and it
doesn't matter
so he has that in the movie that's money
that's security
right
and then he meets this girl named pia
and he's completely infatuated by her
it's exciting and it's new well that's
the girl in the story it's exciting and
it's new
he's always needed money and security
but excitement has taken over does he
choose excitement
and then of course the woman's husband
who's his best friend is the police
that's the people who are going to hold
him accountable
they're going to he he's going to he's
going to have to suffer a consequence
whether it's good or bad he's got to
suffer a consequence
that friend is going to make him pay
he's making him pay the whole movie when
you're watching you're just like geez
you almost consider
the friend to be the bad guy until you
realize this guy has a wife but he's
infatuated with this other woman right
and that's the dance that is going on in
this entire film
so
i look at it and i go you know
the film may be hard to understand it
may be hard to understand
uh
how to relate to it and how this relates
to you but for a specific group of
people they'll understand that desire to
fit in
and that you don't even know yourself
and that you're driven by what you want
in the moment but do you even really
want it do you know yourself enough to
know you really want it
and
i think there is a segment of of
audiences that can relate
you know but then there'll also be a
segment that'll say i don't even get any
of this and it's because they don't
relate to any of it
they just don't but that movie's not for
them
sure or maybe they've seen that in
someone close to them
or or they used to be that and then they
realize all that's empty but but i i see
what you mean someone that's really
conflicted they want what they want
they're willing to kind of sell their
soul for it yeah yeah i think that's a
that's a good story to write about
hollywood mm-hmm
it is and it's him he's he's
he's just in the wind because he doesn't
know himself anymore
sure he doesn't
how long did it take you to write the
script
i started writing it
in probably
2017 2018 i started writing it
but it was one of those ones where i
just kind of plugged away at it for a
little bit at a time and then i got to a
point where i said i i don't know
where i should take this story and then
what happened was i put it aside for a
moment
and i went off and i did some other work
and it was around that time that i
realized man you know the reason why i
didn't know where to go with this story
was because i was trying to
[Music]
stick a hollywood ending on it
and it's funny because that's actually a
line in the earlier in the script is
that he was saying you know he's taking
advice from the character p and he says
i can't take that advice because it's
not a very hollywood ending
and she tells him well
hollywood ending all depends on where
you stop the story
and so
i i said to myself i have to be honest
in the rest of the screenplay i have to
be honest and i have to make him have
real conversations
about
where he's headed where his
relationships are headed where his life
is headed he has to have these real
conversations now he can't have them the
way that we have them
but he has to have them
and he has to make a decision
it can't be ambiguous he has to make a
decision and so once i went back into
the script with that mandate you know i
was able to wrap it up pretty quickly i
was going to rep it pretty quickly and
pretty honestly
and with as much truth as possible
did you give the script to many people
for feedback
no
no
um
i i think feedback is great sometimes
but when it's something that's very
it was very new for me to be that honest
and not truthful and not try to stick
like you know hollywood
stuff into hollywood magic to make it
magically resolve
i didn't want that type of feedback
i wanted i wanted it to exist for what
it was
so you didn't need to get notes from
anybody because you self-financed it
and so
you just knew you were but were there
any parts that maybe were unclear that
you wanted people to see and
flesh out for the characters or no you
just knew we were going to do it this
one way i knew i was going to do it that
one way what i did was once i got actors
on board who were
very very talented and they were very
outspoken about their own thoughts on it
um
i was able to just have a conversation
with them where i said free like there
are no wrong answers okay but we're just
going to sit down and we're going to
talk about the script and we're going to
talk about the moments and how we can
make them honest
and very truthful
so let's have those conversations and
like i said it was very productive
because no one was saying but i think it
should end this way or i think it should
establish very early on
the theme of the movie and where it's
headed is not changing
how we get there may adjust a little bit
but
where this train is headed it already
left the station and it's headed to this
destination
so we all sat down and we said okay cool
in these moments here are things that we
can do to make it more truthful and make
it feel more honest
and that's really what we focused on so
there were some changes along the way
but for the most part
what was on the page was on the screen
for the most part i got i got very very
close i would say
i would say i was 75 there
75 of what i wanted is on the screen
which is a high number for me
what do you tell other screenwriters
filmmakers about being too precious
about certain scenes that maybe they
just don't totally serve the story um
i haven't had to have that conversation
however that conversation was had with
me
and it was had by eddie watkins
[Music]
he told me he said um
your biggest problem
is that you're married to everything you
do
you can't be that way
especially if you're not the one
financing and directing it you can't be
things are going to have to change for
whatever reason and you're going to have
to be open to making whatever those
changes are work
and that's what i would tell anybody
who's treating it too precious
so because you know we all like
want certain scenes or some little
artifact in the film and it means
something to us but the audience might
not care
and and so
when people have given you those notes
or maybe it was just ed
are you open to changing them or has it
been hard for you
to take notes and to remove certain
things
um
in the past
i would say i was probably more
open to removing it even if i didn't
agree i'd remove it
because
i want this issue to die and i don't
want things to
keep carrying over or whatever
but
once i started to just kind of stand up
and say no this is this is my film even
if you pay for it it's my film because
ultimately nobody's going to say
you know
well i looked at this movie that
producer must have been great that's not
what they're going to say they're going
to say the director and the writer and
the cast were great that's what they're
going to say and if people know a little
bit more about the industry they're
going to say the cinematographer was
great
but what they're not going to say is wow
that producer really knows his stuff
that just doesn't happen you know and so
what happened is is that we made the
film and we always understood what it
was supposed to be
and then as we got further along
people's
uh
ego started to get involved
and even though i would explain i
understand that this is great for you
but we are at service to the story
not
to you
so the person would relent
and so as we got further into editing
the conversations would come up again
well i think we should really add this
and i'm like you're serving your own ego
you're not really serving the story so
no i don't think we should do that and
so we would go have a little bit back
and forth until i would just say okay
you know what
just so we can
be done with it and then you would cut
it and before you know it it was a movie
that was granted at 2 hours and 15
minutes it's a bit long so we
we cut it down to about maybe
an hour 45 minutes so now it's cut down
only that needs to happen is color and a
little bit of sound working and it's
ready to be done
so
i hand it off and ultimately
i heard through the grapevine that the
film was finished and that it was at an
hour and a half
it's really weird
[Laughter]
it's really weird
something and it was because
i have to take
accountability and responsibility
i handed off the film along with all the
footage so that it could have the
finishing touches put on it
and what ultimately happened was
this person decided to put all these
scenes back in and remove all these
other scenes
so that their work would stand out a bit
more
and it was an ego thing
you know
and i said you know what i i dropped the
ball on that one because i gave that
person the ability to do it that was
that was my fault and it'll never happen
again
it'll never happen again
um because that film floats around and
people say wow that film
and i i can't take
i can't take credit for the good or the
bad because it's not my film
it's not
and that was because i started in the
beginning
you know talked about
the tv show 24. and uh jack bauer you
know when the guy says ah you know um
you've never done anything bad you've
never made a bad decision you've never
just done this one little thing and he
says no because once you do that one
little thing it makes it easier to do
the second thing and the third thing and
that one thing that i did was that i
compromised and i did it just so that
the conversation would die
i said ah
just
and i gave in a little and a little bit
more and a little bit more
and then eventually the film completely
changed
and i said you know i just won't allow
that to happen again if i do work with
someone else the film that they'll
receive to do any type of finishing
touches which by the way i'll do them
all
in house so that when i hand it off it's
a finished film
but let's just say that i had to hand it
off they would only get the film to work
with and that would be it
because it's my responsibility to make
sure
that
you know we're honest to the film and
what the film is trying to say we're in
service of the film
not to our egos
we had this comment come in on our
channel
in a horror movie only the villain
character matters all the other
characters are expendable most are going
to die anyway
what's your reaction to that
i don't think that's true
if if no one matters they shouldn't be
in the film
if it's only about that villain then he
should be yo-yoing or you know doing
something else that only requires you
know him
i think that you're trying to tell a
story and every character is integral to
that story or they shouldn't be there
maybe that comes from me
working with limited budgets always and
you're constantly saying you know
why is this person here does this person
need to be here because they're going to
impact me and as far as scheduling as
far as the budget
and it helps you hone your screenwriting
skills better too because there's
nothing extraneous about the script
so to say at any stage that none of
these people matter i think if you're
watching
the later
friday the 13th movies if you're
watching the later
freddy movies or the later halloweens
but if you're watching the ones that
they started with
you would not say anybody was extraneous
in those stories
they that's when they were still very
creative and they had spent a lot of
time working on the script and you know
they gave a lot of thought towards it
and it was written with love and
when you do that when the screenwriter
loves those characters there's no way
they will be creating people that don't
matter
it's no way
how does a villain in a story reflect
the hero
um oof if you had asked me this a long
time ago
um now i say sometimes my villain and my
my
hero are almost one in the same
they have to pursue whatever their goal
is with the same amount of passion i
think that one person learns lessons and
the other person doesn't and
that's ultimately what does in the
villain and the villain has to reflect
whatever it is or i shouldn't say that
villain has reflected but
their goal has to reflect something that
the hero is trying to work through
so that they can work through there's a
catharsis you know as they go through
this journey
and get to the end and stop this thing
from happening i think that's the way
that it should go but i i think that
they should both
pursue their goals with the same passion
and intensity
because that's what makes for a great
villain i still consider the best
villain to be alan rickman's character
in die hard i think he is the best
villain ever
because his goal
you know is is the opposite but they're
working towards the same thing which is
him and john mclean it's just that
they're going about it differently
but they're both after this their goals
with the same amount of passion and
intensity and being clever they're both
very clever that's the other thing about
it like both
both of them are trying to one-up the
other one and get one over on the other
and that's what's so compelling about
watching that story
i think it should be the same with with
any movie that you're working on whoever
is your antagonist
should be going after with the same
amount of intensity and passion
they should be almost a mere reflection
of the of the good guy if maybe
they made all the wrong decisions in the
past maybe they didn't make that 51
percent that warren buffett talks about
maybe they only made the 49 and they
they weren't successful at certain
things
should the antagonist be twice as strong
as the hero
no
i think that
the
villain should always have
an advantage
and most of the time if if you think
about it if you using
alan rickman's character in in die hard
um
his advantage was that he already knew
what he was trying to accomplish
that was his advantage he knew what he
was trying to accomplish
and because people would say oh well he
had the numbers too he had all these
guys with guns yeah but they didn't know
who they were looking for
and they didn't know where he was
so
that put them put them at a disadvantage
the advantage of the good guy i mean the
bad guy actually had the villain was
that he knew what he was trying to
accomplish and john mclean had to figure
it out
so i i think you know i don't think he
has to be twice as strong he just needs
to be ahead of the game
and the good guys playing catch up
but you say
in the in the end that the antagonist
doesn't learn any lessons but the hero
does
so the the antagonist is just
it's just all anger it's all trying to
get revenge
but the hero somehow learns something
the hero has to learn something he
really does uh the villain i don't think
it has to be about anger
i there have been many villains that
have done things
give you an example moon and the stars
my villain isn't a guy who's really
trying to kill everybody
as a matter of fact he's trying to save
everyone
he's just going about it in a really bad
way what he started to notice he's been
to the edge of the universe and back
he's been to the beginning of time in
the end and what he's seen is that every
civilization
every leap every technological leap they
make gets them closer and closer to
oblivion
what drives those technological leaps is
hope
hope hope that things can be better hope
that this makes the world a better place
hope that this gets us to here and hope
that this gets us to there and
what we don't account for is what
happens when we
make those very
when we make those mistakes or when
somebody takes what we were using for
hope and they weaponize it
um
those are the things that don't get
accounted for so what his idea is is to
create a machine
that
it shrinks this olympic area in the
brain so that hope dies
the problem is when hope dies so does
ambition so there's love so this fear
so many other emotions die and what what
happens after that is that
his project showed success right it and
people had no hope
but then what happened is whether it was
a day later or a month later people
would off themselves
and if they didn't off themselves they
became
something different
and it became very much like the order
of fenu
that he that works with him to do these
things
so
his
goal
is not one that's out of anger it's one
that's out of love and you find out that
it's to save the people that he still
cares about because he's seen what
happens in the future
so he needs this to work
now
the good guys know if you do this it's
the same as a death sentence because
it's a ticking time bomb for people just
offing themselves
just killing themselves
so he's working just as hard to keep
this guy from succeeding
so i don't i don't think it has to be
anger or hatred or or any of those
things it just has to be a goal that
they really believe in that they are
just they've given everything there is
no plan b there is only plan a both
people have a plan a
and what do you do when they're just ah
they're about to collide
you know
that's where the drama comes from that's
where it gets interesting
and if your bad guy was only driven by
revenge
i've seen that a million times driven by
anger you can beat the anger out of
somebody i've seen it happen a million
times you know get into a boxing ring
and this guy is angry
he won't have all that in three rounds
because he's gonna swing for the fences
he'll be exhausted and you can beat the
anger out of him and he'll give up
because that's all he had was anger
so
the most compelling stories come from
the people who really believe in their
goal and they're willing to die for
their goal
what makes the villain fail is their
inability to grow and adapt
because adaptation is survival right and
the good guy figures it out they when
they're beaten in that you know into the
second act when they're beaten
they have to pick up the pieces
and learn their lesson
and they're like
i still have the same goal
i just got to go about it differently
and
the
bad guy
thinking that he's one already
when he sees the bad guy show up again
what does he do the same exact thing he
did to win last time
and that's why he loses
why is evil important in storytelling
i think it depends on the definition of
evil
um
i think that
sometimes people
will say evil is like oh they do these
horrible things and like if somebody
takes it just as an example and i'm not
defending at all but let's say they take
someone like hitler right and they say
you see all the horrible things he did
just evil
i go
i think he's despicable
i think the atrocities are evil
but true evil
is doing it just because
that's true evil he didn't do it just
because
he did it because he believed this and
he believed that and he believed this
crazy stuff
and he was like the only way to do it is
to do this to me true evil is something
that is is birthed rotten
and
it has no reason to exist other than to
cause you harm
true evil is terrifying true evil
doesn't need a reason
it just doesn't michael myers did not
need a reason that's what made him so
terrifying
nothing happened to make him stab his
sister and her boyfriend to death
nothing happened
that's scary
i think you very rarely though see true
evil in movies because it's something
hard to capture
it's something really hard to capture
people that just do things because
why not
those are the things that i think in in
reality scare the crap out of me
when you hear about this serial killer
who should you ask why did you do this
why not
that's evil
that's terrifying
but it's really rarely portrayed very
well in films
how do you create a powerful and
meaningful story i think it first has to
be
powerful and meaningful to you
i i try to
now
as i write if i'm writing something that
i
story i just have to tell
it has to a lot of the time speak to
something maybe that i'm dealing with
myself
and
i get i can work through a lot of it in
the script
you know and i think that's why it wakes
me up because it's something that
i'm figuring out that i'm working
through and i'm working through it with
characters
so i think it starts there it has to be
important and impactful for you
and from there you can begin to shape it
so that
it's something that is easily digestible
for somebody who's maybe not
experiencing the same things as you
or
you know they're not going on that same
journey with you
so you want to make it more relatable so
that you know they can certainly see
that journey and take that journey with
you
what if someone asked you to write a
screenplay and you know for hire and
it's not a story that necessarily you
tap into but you're being paid well and
you say all right i'll do it but you
just can't relate to the character to
the story to the theme to the tone
um
funny enough that just happened
and ultimately we long story short we
just couldn't work together that's just
what it was oh wow okay the
you know the story was just something i
can't relate to and
the way i would have to be able to tell
the story
that other
person who was the financier
they didn't
they didn't want the story to go that
direction
so we were at an impasse
and we both had to say i don't think
this is going to work for either of us
because
what you want
won't wake me up in the middle of the
night
that message is not a message that
speaks to me
it's not a it's a throwaway message and
i wouldn't want to create something
that and spend months working on
something that i don't believe in
i just i wouldn't want to do that to
myself and i wouldn't want to do that to
someone who's paying me the money to do
it i just i think it's it's a bad idea
so yeah that actually happened to me
recently
and did you know fairly um soon into
you're working with the person that this
wasn't going to work this is going to
happen
i didn't know it early enough
i allowed us to go down the road too far
and waste a lot of each other's time
and
i normally don't consider something to
be a waste of time if i learn a lesson
but
i think i learned i think i understood
things
far sooner and i just let it drag on
because i believed at some point
he would see what i was saying and as he
began to speak with his partners they
would see what i was saying
but unfortunately much like me he didn't
have
he did have partners but they were out
of the way they didn't have any
influence on the project so their
opinions didn't matter
so we're both people who don't report to
anybody
so we both you know we had to just shake
hands and say it's not going to work
that's fair yeah
it's better that you cut your ties then
than actually had it made and it wasn't
exactly what you felt well i wouldn't
have been able to write it i just
i think that uh
when you when you sit down to write
something
you you understand that it's a journey
right
and for some people it's not about the
it's not about the destination it's just
the journey but i'm constantly keeping
both
in in mind the journey and the
destination journey and the destination
so i know if this is the destination we
agreed to to get to this is the best
path
to tell the story
and if that doesn't work
and i see the alternative is an inferior
version to that then i i have to say i
don't think it's gonna click i don't
think it's really gonna click because
that journey won't tell it won't be
honest it won't be honest it's it's it's
forcing something you know and um
i i don't want to
say that but but it's just it becomes it
becomes like you're just pushing
constantly and
trying to force something trying to
force a circle in the square hole and
you shouldn't do that when you're
writing especially in the beginning you
shouldn't do that when you're developing
the screenplay that's when it's fun and
that's when it's breezy
and if you can't see the journey in a
fun and breezy way
then it's time to kind of cut bait don't
don't spend so much time working on it
for something that's
it's not going to be fruitful for you um
in the soul nor
from an experience you know
what are your thoughts on creating a
meaningful story versus one that's
commercial
i think it all depends on your goals
if your goal is to create something
commercial go for it i think that um
there's no
shortage
of
opportunities to create something
commercial
there's no shortage of it because
as you can see that's what's being
thrown at most of us all the time it's
something commercial that has mass
appeal and i think it's superficial i
think it's easy
um
you can take the money and run it's it's
what they call it legal bank robbery you
know it's if that's your thing
i think that for
a lot of people who are not
for people who are driven by
quelling that voice inside
that won't really work
i think you're always going to have to
be making something meaningful whether
it's meaningful to you or meaningful to
audiences in general
because
that's how you that's how you you feed
that thing inside of you right
um that need to get that that creativity
out you're creating creating something
that means something to you in that
moment
if you're
constantly if you are a person who
desires to make meaningful material
and you're constantly having to stuff
that down while you make something
commercial you're not living your best
life
you're not living your best life
and ultimately that's all we want to do
that's all we want to do as artists is
live our best life create stuff and get
it out there and then create something
again and get it out there and for for a
great number of people creating
something commercial is great
you you go out there it takes you maybe
a couple weeks of work and
it's off you know because when it a lot
of the times for especially for the
stuff now that's like your marvels and
you know anything that's disney related
and it's high concept those guys have a
paint by number formula
you can stack all those movies one on
top of the other and they'll hit the
same beats all the way through
and
you know that's good that's awesome they
know what their audiences want
and those writers have an easy job they
know by this moment this needs to happen
by this moment this needs to happen
if that feeds their soul or their bank
account
i say power to them hopefully it does
both
hopefully does both
but if you desire to make meaningful
content you really have to get that out
even if it's if you're a writer it's
just writing the script
just purging it getting it out of your
system
and then you turn around and you write
something commercial but you have to get
out of your system you have to feed that
beast
why is it so hard to make a great movie
that's a good one
i think one it depends on your
definition of great
i think that so many people are caught
up and everybody else said it was great
and i think that's where most movies go
wrong
somebody will tell somebody oh your
movie's like this but with a little bit
of that and they go
i didn't see that but okay and then they
go back and they start looking at that
movie and they want to polish it now and
make it a little bit more like that
movie and it's it's that whole
it's that whole like looking at the guy
next to you thing
you know and judging yourself by how far
you've gotten ahead of everybody else
that you're that is your peer or your
you know your colleague or whatnot
trying to try to just get ahead of them
and judging yourself judging your
success by how much more success you've
had than them
and that includes making a great movie
i consider a great movie to be one where
i watched that movie and i couldn't turn
it off
i couldn't turn it off
that's watching it though i couldn't
turn it off um
one of
one of my favorite movies
uh
is 44 inch chest nobody's seen it
um well i shouldn't say that let me not
say nobody's seen it
most people in the u.s haven't seen it
but it's called 44 inch chest i love
that movie from beginning to end and
then i went online one day and i saw the
reviews and i'm like i was like what
i don't get it this movie was incredible
i mean i i couldn't take my eyes off the
screen it was so well written
every element of filmmaking was done
to the nth degree i just didn't
understand it right
so i don't know if
certain people walked away going i guess
we didn't make a great movie you know i
felt they made a great movie
i felt they made one of the best movies
ever i did and it's a small little movie
takes place in a flat you know
i think it's an incredible movie i think
it's a great movie
a lot of other people didn't think so
but maybe the person who made the movie
said that's exactly what i wanted to
make
because that's how i would feel
when i sit down and i watch a film of
mine
it's all about how much of what was in
here made it on the screen and if it
made it on the screen it went one day
when i get to
at least 93 percent of whatever i wanted
to being on the screen i'm gonna say
that's a great movie
that's a great movie
that's a successful movie
i've made something successful
because that's what success means to me
that's what a great movie made by me
means right
and i'm hopeful that that person who
made 44-inch chess felt that way because
maybe people don't feel that that was a
great movie
you said it was a foreign film
it's it's made in the uk um
it has uh
ray
uh
it's gonna bother me that i can't
remember his name but um hum leota no no
no no no not rayleigh uh he was in he
was in uh um
uh
the
the jack nicholson movie when he played
the gangster the irish gangster
um
with leonardo dicaprio and
uh
all those guys i can't remember his name
right off the top of my head but you've
seen him a million times and when you
see forty four hours oh fine
no it's like i wanna say it's like roy
i mean ray like i don't know why i want
to call it like [ __ ] bird or something
like that but i know that's not what it
is but it's
as soon as you see him you're going to
say oh that guy you know but it's it's
him it's so many people so many names so
many people that you're going to
recognize immediately right as soon as
it starts you're going to see four
people you've seen in every movie you've
ever seen and you're gonna say oh
okay but they're all uk actors right
and the story is very simple
there's a 44 inch chest and there's a
guy inside of there and the main
character the protagonist is trying to
decide should he kill him or not kill
him
very simple premise he invites his
friends over his friends are gangsters
just like he's a gangster and they're
trying to help him work through his
problem to decide if he should kill this
guy do you know who this guy is this is
the guy that's been sleeping with his
wife
in the whole movie i'm not ruining it
that's the movie they're trying to
decide should he kill the guy or
shouldn't he
that's the whole movie and i'm telling
you it is a perfect movie from start to
finish
does it take place in one room
it doesn't take place in one room but
definitely in one one flat okay one flat
it it's um
incred it's it's done to
an incredible level of filmmaking
writing directing
editing score everything is incredible
the acting is impeccable
the special effects are impactable yes
there are special effects even in this
this small film um everything was done
so perfectly so the definition of great
is really
you know kind of subjective in terms of
why is it so hard to make a great movie
i think if you have succeeded at
accomplishing what you wanted to
accomplish and you you feel successful
in it
it's a great movie in terms of one that
you've made
now
if you are talking about
just watching movies yeah there's a lot
of movies that will let you down you
know and maybe maybe maybe this person
who thinks that they made a great movie
was just like a guy who i was telling
you about who stunted his growth because
all he's concerned about is how he
measures up against the other filmmakers
that he knows in his peer group
and if he's thinking about that
and he's constantly throwing in stuff
and falling back on bad habits and never
growing
he may be satisfied but he hasn't made a
great movie
you know i think that you have to be
beyond that um one of the
one of the best uh
you know quotes is is from uh the art of
war where it talks about you know making
yourself invincible
right
and invincible doesn't mean
that you can't uh that you win that
doesn't mean you win um all that
invincible means is putting yourself
beyond the possibility of defeat and the
only way to do that is by truly knowing
yourself you truly know yourself
and not
spend your time so concerned with what
everybody else is doing it's one of the
reasons why i took down my personal
profile on facebook i don't want to know
what everybody else is working on i just
want to focus i just want to focus and i
want to grow that's all i want to do is
focus and grow
and so
you have to be without that vanity you
have to be without that ego so that you
you have the ability to grow and when
you are making something
your constantly growing and getting
better and you can understand what
didn't work what did work
you can understand how could i have
better communicated that so that it
ended up on the screen the way that i
wanted it to
and
how close did i get to the vision that i
had in my head
how close did i really truly get
and even with one to one where i
consider it to be
my best film to date if you ask me how
close i got i'd say 75 if i'm being
generous with myself
from being generous with myself i got 75
i'm trying to get in the 90s
i'm trying to get in the 90s
and so that i can consider it a great
film
so that i can consider it a successful
film
i find that our greatest enemy besides
constant comparing yourselves to your
peers
the enemy of great
or the enemy of good is sometimes trying
to be great as opposed to just trying to
make the best movie possible you're
trying to be great
don't try to be great just try to be
truthful and honest to the story
to your characters
try that
be as honest and truthful as you can in
that moment that story like i said made
that truth may not resonate with
everybody in the sense of it's their
truth
but they have to understand that you
were being honest when you were making
this film
one of the 48 laws of power
that i feel that people overlook
is the one that it says
always know your effing with
in this industry it's so easy to just
cast someone aside
and say
this person is nobody
person doesn't matter
this person
isn't someone that can help me get to
the next wrong
because you're so caught up in yourself
right
you always have to take time
to and i'm gonna back out of it to say
it from another perspective you always
have to step outside of what you're
trying to accomplish
and understand that your
main objective too
is to be of use
and to be helpful
because if you're of use and helpful
people like to have you around
if you're willing to share your
knowledge and your experience people
love to have you around
so don't think about always what someone
else can do for you
understand what you can do to help them
as well
in all of that never
treat someone as if they're
insignificant
or if they don't matter
always
know who you're effing with
because you never know that one person
could have been the key to an
opportunity that would have completely
changed your life
you have no idea even if you are you
know i preach so much about taking your
destiny in your own hands
but you don't have the ability to
control
much of anything outside of yourself
these other people can open doors for
you
and it may be that maybe you open the
door for them and you just walk through
with them maybe you just help this
person go to the next level and then
they say you know what i remember that
time this guy
you just never know
so always know who you're effing with
you know which law is that that's good
oh i don't know which one it is but it's
in the 48 laws of power always know who
you're having with you know i have to go
back to it yeah maybe maybe i'll
re-listen
yeah
i mean that that book is
i think it's a
a more timely
version of art of war
so i think sure i think it's it's better
written for for this
period
justin we had this comment come in from
one of our viewers and it reads guys i'm
so scared there are a certain amount of
movies i want to create and i figured
the best route to start would be with
screenwriting but i just wish i had a
guide or something for the journey it
seems like people really spend years
doing so much work and only have results
after like a decade i'm not sure if i
want to be a screenwriter but i do know
that i have movies i want made
help what advice can you all give me
so
wow
pictures that he wants to get made but
not quite sure how to go about it and
doesn't want to spend decades doing
something he doesn't love or she don't
you know doing stuff they don't love
in order to make that happen
i would say pick a discipline and
know that that's your focus
and just start making stuff
just start making stuff i think
everybody gets so caught up in all the
reasons why they can't do something they
never think about why they can
and i don't know what that is about us
as artists that
that makes that thought pop into your
head but
whenever i do something my my wife will
tell you i tell you a thousand and one
reasons why we'll succeed and you'll
have to tell me all the reasons why we
can't and i'll tell you every reason why
i can overcome that too
that's really what it's about get out
there and make it happen
just get out there and make it happen if
you know that screenwriting isn't where
you want to be see if you can get
somebody who is a screenwriter to do
that part of it
and then you just get out there and you
make it i don't know what it is this
person was trying to
to
um
what discipline they were trying to work
in whether it was producing directing
writing acting i don't know but whatever
it is know that that's your main thing
and the pieces that you don't want to
concern yourself with in terms of
learning how to do it and becoming very
proficient
i would say peace peace work that
peacemail that out like get someone else
who is just as eager to create something
as yourself
and say let's create this together you
handle that part i'll handle these parts
and just do it that way and just get to
creating just start creating stuff
have you always had that belief in
yourself
where you can think of all these reasons
why you will succeed
no no i don't think i've always had that
i think that i've always been
i think i've always been by myself
wanting people to include me in
something
and
i went through my life with that
until one day i no longer cared what
everybody else was thinking or doing or
willing to accept me
and that's what was able to help me
become more and more successful
because i realized
the only
difference between like i'm the only
difference between possible and
impossible that's really it
i am
so
if that is the truth then i don't really
need any of these other people i don't
need their approval i don't need their
guidance i don't i don't need anything i
can go over here and start making my own
mistakes when i speak to someone else i
want to learn from their mistakes that's
what i want to learn from whatever
advice you have it came from your
mistakes i want to know about your
mistakes if you have something to share
if you don't just don't stand in my way
you know because the train is moving
this direction if you stand there i'll
run you over because this is where i'm
going so i don't really need any of it
um i can i can i came to a realization
that when i made adam k adam k if you
look at it i had to make up credits
because i didn't want to look like i did
everything but i did everything
i did it was me and my wife
she handled
holding the boom pole
she did makeup she did special effects
she handled catering
and um
i
handled everything else
you know and it was the two of us making
a movie
and we made it for 1500 bucks and
everybody thinks we spend a crapload
more than that but nope that's all we
spent
and
it was proof i don't need
a bunch of people to make that happen
and neither does anyone else
sit down take a camera or camera phone
or something and start shooting
something
was there a specific incident or
something that happened that made you
realize i don't i don't need
the group
um
that you're willing to share no i mean i
think it i think more than anything it
was it was the constant
disappointment
because
when you're starting out and you don't
have very much money
you
you start to see who will work with you
for very little money right
so their incentive is only that very
little money that's it it's not the
passion it's not growing with you it's
not any of that stuff they have no
investment in your journey or theirs
whatsoever they want that 50 bucks or
100 bucks that you can pay them and
guess what happens if somebody else
comes along and says they'll give them
200 bucks they will be off your set and
you will be there by yourself and that
happened to me excuse me numerous times
numerous times
where people would just bail i was
shooting something a short film and they
just bail and that's it or they don't
show up and you're like what what is
this you know
and so
i went into to adam k and i just i
wanted to see can i shoot this myself i
shot another film called bleed for me
and i shot that one completely by myself
that one was me taking the boom pole and
propping it up in a corner so that it
would capture audio and then i would
shoot with it with the camera and i
would be setting up the lights and i
would order food and bring it over you
know i literally shot bleed for me by
myself
and edited it
you know
but it was because so many people that i
brought aboard flaked just flaked and
flaked and flaked and i just i began to
realize i don't need any of these people
actually
i mean it's good to have them around you
know it lightens the load a bit but i
don't need them
and so once i once i really realized
that my only reason for bringing someone
on board if i have the money to pay them
well
you only
your your
the reason why you're on this project is
because you do something better than i
could myself
and you truly do lighten the load but if
it's something that i realize at any
point that i'm just better off doing it
myself i will
i'll just do it myself
because it's better off that way
how does someone maximize their chances
for breaking in
in hollywood whatever breaking in is
um
[Music]
in the shortest answer
the same way
you can increase your odds of winning a
boxing match throw a whole lot of
punches
now does that mean you win no it just
gives you
a puncher's chance right so if you just
keep taking your shot taking your shot
taking your shot eventually something
will land hopefully
now
if you're looking at a more skillful way
to get there and to continue to work i
say perfect your craft
and constantly take opportunities to
get more experience and to be helpful
to put yourself in a position to better
utilize
those muscles and those strengths of
yours and and make those weaknesses no
longer a weakness make them an advantage
you know start to do that so that you
become
you become not only
better at the craft
but you can navigate the system a little
bit better because that is more helpful
but i think those are the ways you you
increase your odds as well
in a more calculated way
and i i tell people too i tell this to
actors i tell this to writers i tell it
to anybody
keep creating your own content
keep creating because even though you no
one's going to come
looking just odds nobody's going to come
looking at your web series and saying
that needs to be on nbc that's not
really happening
but
what it does it allows you to grow it
allows you to do what most people would
do in a film school which is you get to
fail
and fail
and fail
and fail until you're no longer failing
right
our greatest enemy is that we keep
waiting for someone as someone to give
us a shot and if you haven't had enough
shots
you're just failing under their watchful
eye
that's all you're doing
so why not do that on your own
you know just shoot some stuff
get more experience work through your
strengths understand what your strengths
are and what your weaknesses are and
begin to work through those things and
make those you know your advantages as
well and just become all around
uh a great technician in your craft as
well as a great creative in your in your
craft